Hello everybody.
This episode of the podcast is brought to you by Squarespace,
the all in one platform that makes it fast and easy to create your own
professional website.
There was a time not long ago where it was impossible do what you can do with
Squarespace.
You had to learn html or you had to learn a program that processes html was a
huge pain in the ass.
You had to hire some fucking flaky dude,
probably would never get your website done on time and even when he did weren't
probably happy with it and you could get a really professional website.
You could do it yourself on Squarespace and you could do it really easily.
Brian has done,
I don't know,
dozens of them during the time that we've done commercials,
like literally in the,
in the time we're doing a Squarespace commercial,
by the time the commercial's over,
he's had a website drag and drop interface.
Super simple to use.
It's if you can attach a photograph to your email,
you can use Squarespace.
Truly is that easy.
They offer 24 seven support,
very easy to set up an online business as well.
You can have an online account where you can sell digital downloads like music
or comedy or something along those lines.
You can sell products.
It's very,
very easy to do a plan,
start at $8 a month,
which includes a free domain name.
If you sign up for a year,
responsive design,
that will look awesome.
And any device I iPhones,
android devices,
Unix,
if you're one of those fucking Weirdos,
if you're one of those,
uh,
Linux guys,
it'll work.
Squarespace has a logo creator.
We can create a clean,
simple logo design for yourself in minutes and for a free trial and 10% off your
first purchase,
go to squarespace.com and enter the code word,
show that squarespace.com and enter the code word Joe Squarespace.
A better web starts with your website.
That's the part that they wrote.
That shit's wack.
You guys need to rewind that.
Uh,
we're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com mm.
That's for people who hate slurp and that's all for you
on an as a human optimization website.
And what we sell is everything that I and my friend Aubrey have found to be
beneficial as far as performance,
as far as cognitive performance,
as far as strength and conditioning equipment.
We sell the finest products we can find,
whether it's kettlebells,
battle ropes,
a steel maces,
steel clubs.
If you didn't know any better and you went there,
you'd think that we're starting some sort of a weapons arsenal.
But all of these things are actually just tools to develop functional,
physical strength.
Um,
if you are into a,
any sort of,
um,
athletic endeavor,
martial arts,
um,
any,
any sort of sport,
the,
the key to any weightlifting or any strength and conditioning training is
getting your body to move as one unit.
Not isolating specific muscle groups,
but getting the whole body to use,
uh,
all the muscle groups together in conjunction in coordination.
And that's the kind of equipment that we sell it on on a.com.
That's o n n I t including supplements.
Uh,
the,
the finest stuff that we find all of it backed with research references,
science.
It's a all available at [inaudible] dot com go to o,
n n I t use the Codeword Rogan and you can save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right,
Dan savage is here.
Why fuck around.
Cue The music.
No,
Jamie the Joe.
Well,
good experience Joe Rogan podcast all day.
There are very few men out there in the world that are allowed to be sex
experts.
You sir,
have pulled it off.
I don't know how man pulls that off,
but congratulations to you.
Thank you.
It was an accident and will sometimes that's the best way.
The only way people write me all the time at my stupid sex advice column saying
they want to be advice columnist when I grew up.
How do you get the Gig and and can I give them any help?
Or was like,
well fuck you.
I'm not going to help you compete with me.
It was only a certain number of papers.
You can be syndicated and there's fewer papers than ever because of the Internet
and everything killing in print.
So what I'm looking to help you start to advice column,
but don't you think that if someone out there had an interesting viewpoint that
perhaps you could maybe benefit from it?
Oh,
absolutely.
I,
I read widely.
I just not in the business of helping people start businesses that compete with
my business.
Isn't that famine thinking?
Isn't that like a little bit,
well,
everyone in print is of course engage in a lot of famine thinking.
Yeah.
Because it is famine in print right now.
That's um,
that's a hard market.
Unless you're in a place where you absolutely no,
there's no Wifi.
Like you're in a place,
a plane going over the Pacific and you don't have an iPad with you,
then you're stuck with print.
You are,
that might be the only time we have to use print.
Now.
I was a little upset when they got Wifi on airplanes and I'm old enough to
remember when they didn't have wifi on airplanes because that was,
that had become the one place where I could read a book.
Why would actually sit and read without reading three lines and checking my
Twitter and reading three lines of checking my Twitter.
For me,
it's writing.
It's one of the features
times where I could lock in,
put headphones on and get writing done where I know for sure that I wouldn't
have any interruptions or distractions or couldn't surf the web and we'll check
things out.
As a writer,
I write for a living,
I read my column and books and Shit.
I want to find the person who decided it was a really great idea to make the
same thing that I write on the same thing that can deliver me all the
pornography in the world all at once.
But this,
this one devices where you work,
but it's also where all the pornos.
Yeah,
it's like your father's office being under his bed with all the playboy
magazines in the fifties you know,
this is an interesting thing that I wanted to get to because porn in the gay
community is very different than porn in the straight community because porn and
the straight community,
regardless of who you know that does it.
That's a nice person and that claims to love sex.
There's always an of exploitation attached to it.
Where is in the gay community?
I know gay porn stars,
I know guys who,
you know,
like gay porn,
they don't have any problem with it.
It's a completely different sort of a scenario.
Well I know I've known some straight people who were important porn and straight
women who made porn and I know straight women,
sex workers or some friends of mine.
I don't think that those two things necessarily have to be bolted together.
I think they are bundled together and a lot of porn produced for the straight
market because when I see,
when I look at porn made frustrated people,
which I do just to keep abreast,
research,
um,
I see the coupling of desire.
This is what I want to do.
This is the person I would like to do it too with revenge,
with anger and frustration because a lot of porn is made for people who can't
get laid otherwise.
That's a large chunk of the porn market.
And so a lot of corporate producers I think consciously or subconsciously mixed
together like the object of your desire with the punishment.
And I'm not just talking about BDSM porn,
I'm talking about mainstream porn and and vanilla porn,
whether it's this kind of,
you know,
desire a on display that the object of your desire and this anger,
if it gets kind of channeled through at the same time,
cause this person that you want to fuck won't fuck you,
but you can watch them get fucked and watch terrible things happen.
That's interesting cause I don't ever see that kind of porn.
Um,
um,
I know it's out there but I don't run into it.
I don't think it's that Canzo revenge.
How calm.
I mean I think when you talk about that exploitation,
I think that exploitation can also be a part of it.
When you get that creepy sense that what's going on here is a little squeaky and
not very consensual and not coming from a place of joy,
mutual pleasure.
I think that's part of it too.
I think there's a continuum,
but then there's also some people that like that,
that are women like Sasha grey absolutely likes,
you know what she calls being a slut.
Like that's her.
Like she gets to when she has gang bangs,
you know,
and she talks about them.
She likes it,
she likes people abusing her.
Like it's this weird thing and she owns it.
Yeah.
And then it's not abuse.
I mean consent is the magic ingredient that turns anything into something.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's a thing that a lot of you know is there are people out there who only
enjoyed that porn if they don't think the performer enjoys it.
Correct.
If they heard the Sasha grey saying,
I made this,
this turned me on.
I loved it.
It kind of ruins it for a whole class of the porn consumer.
Those people need to die.
Yeah,
I agree.
Yeah.
That's not good.
That's like watching murder films because you really want to murder people,
but you get it out that way.
There's a great essay,
this a gay porn star,
Conner Habib,
you say that like gay people or download with porn and nuts of dump about it,
kind of herb.
He was this gay porn star who wrote this great essay called,
why do you hate porn stars so much?
Because everybody watches porn and,
and he's a gay man and he has gets all this grief from other gay people about
being important about making porn it,
but what he does for a living and the hypocrisy in the culture,
like we hate porn stars,
but we're watching so much fucking porn all the time.
Somebody gets out of porn,
which is what everybody says that you should do.
You shouldn't make porn and tries to go be a lawyer or tries to go be a school
teacher.
And then they're driven out of that profession because of their porn career.
So we say get out of it,
but then we make it possible for people to get out of it.
And that essay is great and it'll,
it'll,
uh,
it gives the lie to the idea that gay people are all across the board better
about porn.
And calmer about porn than straight people are a lot of gay people who have the
same hangups.
Well that's it.
I mean if you're talking about leaving porn and trying to get into any sort of
profession,
you would definitely automatically in some sort of a black list,
right?
Not a blacklist.
You just hope that the thing doesn't surface hope that Google does not perfect
face recognition technology anytime soon.
But if it does,
you're doomed.
You are doomed in a way,
which is really odd because anybody who hasn't done any of the things and you
know,
normal porn,
forget about like bondage,
revenge,
anger,
porn,
but just normal people having sex.
Anyone who hasn't done that is the freak that's there,
the Weirdo.
Increasingly,
we all know we all,
we all have porn production studios in our pockets to carry them everywhere we
go,
everybody,
all of our kids are sexting.
I think there should be an I am Spartacus day where one day a year we all tweet
out a dirty picture of ourselves.
Not for not cause anyone wants to see me naked,
but to protect our children because our children are all sexting right now and
if we continue to live in a world where one dirty picture disqualifies you from
all sorts of careers,
public life,
if it can get you Anthony wiener and then all of our children are going to be
fucked when they grow up because they will all have sent those pictures out
already as teenagers.
That's an interesting point of view.
I'm actually pretty optimistic about the fact that I don't think there's going
to be any secrets whatsoever within the next two decades and so I think it's
going to be a moot point.
I think we're going to expose hypocrisy is going to be exposed on a grand scale
within the next couple of deck because of the digital trail.
Yeah.
I just not just the digital trail,
I think it's going to be like getting to the end of the world and finding the
ocean and just going,
okay,
it's all right here.
Fuck.
It's like,
I don't think,
I think there's going to be no way to hide digital information within the next
10 20 years,
so everything anybody does.
It's like when we were kids and we had questions,
I'm 46 you're 49 w roughly the same age.
When we were kids,
we had questions.
It took a lot of work to find the answer to that question.
You got to go somewhere.
He had to read something.
You had to maybe read a posing sources.
You had to talk to an expert.
It probably maybe didn't need thought though.
That guy wrote that books a fucking idiot and this,
oh,
it was very,
very difficult.
Now you get online and you can find the answers to things within five,
10 seconds.
What we're able to do today was just an alien thought just a few decades ago
when we were kids.
Oh,
within the the the lifespan of my advice,
call me running.
My vice called for 23 years.
For the first decade,
half the questions were,
I call it them definitions,
like what's a butt plug,
but clubs have,
oh,
they have a wiki page.
Now.
If you're,
if you can get out of line to send me an email to ask me what a butt plug is,
you can already have gone to butt plugs,
Wiki page and found out what a butt plug is and how it works.
Yeah,
so many questions that can be avoided today.
So much information is free and I think that that trend,
the trend of the,
the access to information,
it's going to continue and it's going to what we call personal,
you know,
people,
personal privacy,
all these different things.
Those are going to be moot points.
I think we're going to have some sort of a weird hive mind going on when it
comes to information and when that does happen,
the ideas of privacy are going to be very strange.
It's going to be very alien.
Just like the ideas of distribution of information today are very alien to
someone who lived in the Columbus to maybe we're going to have sort of an online
private sphere that's public and accessible in a certain way,
but uh,
sequestered.
There'll be a line between those two identities.
We have this public identity and this private identity or sexual identity and
they're neither.
Both are equally accessible,
but if you take care too schunk what sexual into your sexual online identity and
shut what's professional and your professional online identity,
maybe people will respect that line down and not punish you for it.
Doubt it.
No,
I think that's coming.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I do.
Why do you think that's coming?
I think it's going to be like pod.
You know there was a supreme court nominee,
I think under Reagan has a picture of surfaces and the pod Ginsburg was his
name.
He was smoking pot so he couldn't get beyond the supreme court.
And then you had Clinton who didn't inhale the pod and then you had George Bush
who wouldn't answer the question of how much blow he did and how much pot he
smoked.
And then along comes Obama who was like,
yeah,
I smoked pot and I inhaled.
That was the point.
And it was totally a nonissue.
Right?
And he's coke too.
I think he had no more totally a nonissue.
We're going to get there with sex and sexting and porn.
And online dirty pics.
We'll have our Anthony wiener who's destroyed by it.
We'll have somebody come along and he'll say,
oh,
that's not my Dick.
In that picture,
they,
we'll have somebody come along and say,
yeah,
that's my deck.
It's pretty awesome,
Dick,
both for me,
for president.
And he'll win and it'll be over.
Just like pot is over as an issue that is qualifies you for public life over one
day.
That dirty picture will be a done issue and over.
Well,
I certainly think that the idea of a dirty picture,
it's not going to be a stigma.
The idea of someone who enjoys pornography or any of those things,
it's not going to be a stigma,
but I don't think that people are going to respect any sort of privacy.
I don't think that people are going to respect any sort of differentiation
between your online sex and you're online.
You know,
privately.
I don't think people would respect privacy.
It's not like people won't go look or won't dig,
but I think that people are going to,
people are going to cleave to different identities,
sort of,
uh,
an online identity.
Uh,
sexual identity,
you know who they are when they're looking for it,
who they are,
when they're watching it,
and what they want to do,
who they are.
And that's going to be sort of separate.
You know,
you're going to maintain two public persona.
You're gonna have an online persona that sexualized,
uh,
where you're hunting or looking or fucking or whatever and you're dirty pictures
and your dirty socks and your online persona that's,
you know,
your Facebook page for your mom.
That's interesting.
I think it's too easy to combine things.
They're just,
I don't,
I don't see any way that separate them,
but people do right now.
How do they do it?
Well,
I know people who have,
uh,
you know,
I have friends,
I have a friend who has a Facebook page that's for his mother and his friends
and his professional context.
And then he has this online fetlife,
which is just,
you know,
fetlife is this kink site for straight people and it's,
his is super kinky,
straight online life.
Um,
and anybody who knows him knows about both.
And I think his mother probably knows if she went looking,
she could find that other one,
but she's not going to go looking for it because she doesn't want to see it.
Right,
right.
Okay.
I see what you're saying.
That's a,
maybe,
maybe you're imagining a much blurrier future than I am are much more tech,
more tech advances.
Yeah.
My future are super blurry futures.
Some crazy hive mind where we're reading each other's minds and living in each
other's lives.
I think that,
you know,
my friend Duncan just got back from this conference on virtual reality and he
saw the newest,
latest,
greatest diversions of Oculus rift and he said it is the most mind blowing thing
he's ever experienced in his lock keyless rift rift is the,
yeah,
the,
the three d reality headsets that you put on,
you put them on and a,
I saw the version which is like one of the first versions and it wasn't that
long ago.
It is pretty cool,
but very pixelated,
very obviously not reality,
but this new one is almost indistinguishable from reality.
You put it on and it looks like you're in a room with a guy playing the piano
and he said it his fucking mind blowing because it's a three degree,
three d dimensional video that what the way they do it is the apparently cover a
person with cameras.
When they filmed this,
they put cameras like all of the person's body and then film the segments so
that the person sees it from a person's point of view,
from a person's perspective and all the possible views.
Like if you turned your head and looked up and looked down,
all those are available.
So,
so when you are inside this,
this virtual world with this headset on and you're looking around,
you see everything as if a person was looking around in that room.
There's no breakup of it.
There's no,
there's no glitch in the matrix where as you're looking around and you go,
oh,
you know,
it can't go that way because they didn't film that way or I can't do this or I
can't do that.
Other point is going to be spectacular.
Everything's going to be spectacular movies.
It's like the idea of sitting in a movie theater and watching some stupid thing
that's being projected onto a screen is going to be as ridiculous as a puppet
show.
That's what I think.
I think that we're going to be involved in some sort of a strange world where
we're this e right now they have to cover people with these cameras,
but I'm sure that as technology increases they'll have a more efficient,
more effective way of handling that sort of a recording of information and we're
going to get to some point where you're going to be able to live someone's life.
Like someone's going to be able to beat Dan savage for a day.
There'll be able to plug in our pity.
The fool puts him to be so exciting as you sit in front of my computer looking
at emails,
well,
there'll be able to read your fucking emails.
That's one thing.
It's going to be very strange.
I don't think there's any way to avoid it.
I think the trend is clearly access to information.
That's the trend.
Um,
and that seems to be what technology is all about.
Technology is all about shortening the amount of distance.
Do you have to go to achieve information tor to access information and I think
that that information is eventually going to become human lives,
human memories,
thoughts and
and then eventually being you.
Creepy.
Yeah.
A little.
But then again,
so is the idea of sending a Dick picture across the world like if you lived
5,000 years ago,
no one would be,
they wouldn't even be able to comprehend the idea.
Oh hopefully.
Yeah.
I hope we get there before that you could pocalypse before the seas rise and the
grid collapses.
Because if we don't have a place to plug in our virtual reality reality than we
can't see.
I'm optimistic about that too.
I'm not buying it.
I'm not appealing to me about that.
Why is that?
What do you think?
Because I'm Catholic.
I'm Catholic.
Well I was sorta Catholic are going to be punished.
Uh No,
not a vengeful God.
Its eventual glacier coming for us now.
Do you think that there's some sort of an ECO pocket pocalypse on its way?
You just can't read the paper without,
you know,
the bats are all dying.
We're putting these beads for are exfoliating face scrubs.
These beads are now everywhere in the oceans and the lakes and the rivers
killing everything.
The plastic or the geiers of uh,
or gyres,
however you pronounce that.
Word of garbage in the Pacific and the Atlantic.
Um,
the co two in the atmosphere that we've reached the tipping point with the
Antarctic ice sheets and they're all going to be gone.
It just,
it just feels like we're building up to some sort of eco apocalyptic orgasm.
Like we're edging the planet and edging ourselves and edging humanity and it's
just going to blow.
I think the issue is that people love a good disaster.
And so that's one of the things that everybody likes to talk about.
But if you pay attention to the world history and disasters happen,
like some mother fucker on Easter island was like,
why are you panicking about cutting down the last tree to build another stone
head?
We need to build the stone heads.
And I'm sure there were people like,
you know what?
Maybe we should cut down all the fucking trees cause we're all going to die.
We could.
And they did anyway.
Like societies have committed suicide.
Yeah,
but that's just one little island.
During that time in New York City was built and the Internet was created and how
the earth is an island.
Yeah.
The earth is an island,
but the earth without us,
even without us,
and I'm not a climate change denier,
but even without the human interaction in the earth,
the earth's climate has fluctuated wildly.
10,000 years ago in North America was covered in a mile high sheet of ice.
Most of North America was under ice,
right?
10,000 years ago.
And that sense,
global warming is way better than what nature had.
I had just naturally for us 10,000 years ago perhaps.
But we have never,
we haven't had co two levels like this and the atmosphere for millions of years,
we are engineering a planet that we did not exist on that was not home to our
species,
was not hospitable to mammals.
We don't know what that's gonna look like when the,
when the planet reverts to 10 million years ago,
we just don't know.
And we're gambling with our existence.
Yeah,
we're certainly gambling with our existence.
I mean,
I think more so with the ocean than anything.
The ocean,
just by pulling all the fish out of the ocean and throwing all the garbage in
the ocean,
it's throwing all the CEO's to in the ocean,
which is cutting off the bottom of the food chain in the ocean that the,
that's the acidification of the ocean.
It's just I,
you know,
I'm not a climate expert either,
but I tend to believe the scientists,
when scientists are all sort of in agreement that the earth is not indeed flat.
I'm like,
all right,
I will concede the point.
I haven't walked to the edges myself,
but I will concede the point.
And all 97 98% of climate scientists agree that we are baking the planet and we
are gambling with our ability to live on this planet and we don't have another
one.
We don't have a spare well,
and I think we should err on the side of doing away with fossil fuels.
We should err on the side of reengineering our existence and how we exist on
this planet to save our lives are saved the lives of our great,
great,
great grandchildren who are the ones are going to be fucked as opposed to just
hoping that we can keep going the way we're going.
And Sarah paling being Sarah Palin about every goddamn thing we touch.
And
what do you mean?
Oh,
you know,
let's all buy a gun and let's go,
let's consume fossil fuels and climate changes.
Not,
not real.
I think she just epitomizes to me that no,
nothing,
uh,
bullshit that's going to get us all killed.
Right?
Yeah.
I see what you're saying.
Um,
well,
I had a guy on the podcast and Randall Carlson,
who was a fascinating guy who's an expert and not just climate change,
but climate change throughout the history of the earth.
And when you talk to him,
the fears of human created catastrophe diminish and the real fears become
natural catastrophes,
which have existed throughout history like gigantic superforecasters,
asteroidal impacts not just one,
but so many of them throughout history that we're just starting to get an
account.
We have,
we have enough of those to worry about and enough times when nature could reset
the planet,
when an asteroid could hit us and wipe us out,
that we don't need to gin up more of those.
We're basically,
we are the asteroid right now.
We are the asteroid that's hitting the planet that is killing,
that's created the species die off now,
uh,
is as big as the species die off when the asteroid hit the planet.
We are the astrocyte.
Humanity is the asteroid.
And so knowing that there could be a super volcano knowing that a,
an asteroid could hit the planet knowing that some natural catastrophe could
happen,
why create an unnatural catastrophe?
Why don't think anybody's advocating creating an unnatural?
But we are.
What I'm saying is that I think that we're going to be okay.
I think that the human race is going to be okay.
I think that when our backs are up against the wall,
innovation and technology will somehow another fine.
Then you need to say,
let's,
let's all say that our backs are against the wall.
Now let's let,
let's,
let's listen to the scientists who are saying,
hello,
our backs are against the wall.
We're talking about a 100 year or 200 year period.
When you're talking about,
you know,
geological time and talking about the life cycles of a planet is infantile
optimally short.
It seems long to us because of our lifespans,
but with the scientists are telling us,
is this reset we cannot adapt through if it happens at a hundred hundred years,
which is what we're
on a pace for.
Well,
I don't think anyone's saying we can't adapt to it.
I don't think they're saying that.
I sang,
we were,
if we're going the way we're going now,
we're going to have serious issues with a lot of the ways we live our lives.
I don't think they're saying we cannot adapt.
I think that would be kind of foolhardy because we certainly could.
Human beings are very flexible.
We've existed through ice ages.
We've existed.
We should start adapting
by having this discussion,
the discussion.
But we're not,
well,
there's dispute online,
but I think that's also because anybody can give an opinion.
I mean,
there's a million people out there that are,
you know,
that have no nothing about climate.
Then insisted it's okay to frack that insisted it's okay to burn coal because we
need the jobs and they assist.
The economy is more important that eventually we'll work this out and then these
sky is falling type people are all just,
you know,
just panicking and we need to just relax and trust the Republicans.
I mean,
there's,
there's a lot of voices out there.
[inaudible] heart of the issue.
Trust God.
Vice did a great piece about climate change in Texas where they went around
interviewing people and nobody believes that the drought and the fires and Texas
have anything to do with climate change.
Whereas 97% of all scientists will tell you this,
everything was climate change.
And they think it's just God fucking with them that if God wants it to rain,
it rains.
And so if it's not raining,
it's not man,
it's not.
I think we did.
It's not altering the climate or disrupting weather patterns.
It's,
it's Jesus is having a sad and so he doesn't want Texas to have rain because
some gay people got married in Boston.
All the part of the adolescent stage of evolution that we're currently in,
I think.
I think that just the issue with people having a voice,
he's a million billion fucking people.
I mean how many Goddamn people are the runners?
7 billion at this point,
right?
350 million in America.
And how many of them have a a fucking Facebook account?
How many of them get on Twitter?
How many of them read a few things from a message board that is some sort of a
pro life pro,
this pro that you know,
God,
Obama's born in Kenya and then they go on and they repeat those things.
You know how many fucking people I've had to have arguments with over chem
trails,
people that believe that the government is spraying things into the sky in order
to create artificial clouds.
It's the most,
I mean,
friends fucking mind numbing conversations and they'll point to a million
different websites written by chimps with a stubby little fingers,
just slam on keyboards and they're convinced that what they're saying is right,
but it's just the amount of voices.
There's just so many voices,
but it's just,
I think we're looking at a brief window where all these voices are being heard
in a strange way where it was never possible before,
but I don't think that we're,
we're looking at is the death of civilization.
Well,
I think we're look at it as where we're becoming aware of the repercussions of
our foolish actions,
but I don't think that necessarily means we're going to all die off.
I think if you look at the way life is right now,
look at life right at this moment.
Best time to live ever by far as far as the history of the world.
Completely agree.
I'm getting better modern dentistry,
medicine scenes.
I will.
Information distribution of information,
access,
Internet communication with each other.
Unprecedented,
better than ever before.
I also think compassion,
but that doesn't mean that doesn't mean we're safe,
that it's better now than ever before.
Doesn't mean it can't go completely haywire.
Wrong.
Save her saying safe saying we're going to be okay.
I don't think we're going to be
AH,
why?
Uh,
because the complacency in your very statement that we're going to be okay is no
complacency induces a kind of passivity.
Maybe not.
You know how you understand what you're saying,
but other people are,
why aren't we all running around with our hair on fire screaming about because
we're existing planet,
but what shouldn't we enjoy our existence?
Shouldn't we enjoy this state that you can enjoy the moments and you can be
concerned for the future existence?
Well,
you can't be,
you can't enjoy it.
If you're saying that we're all gonna die in the sky is falling when
everything's great right now,
we have to be able to game it out into the future and say everything is great
right now.
But looking at the CO2,
looking at what's already happening to the permafrost in Alaska,
looking what's happened to the oceans that we may be living on borrowed time,
that we're going to run out of water.
We're going to run out of a land that can be farmed and we're going to have
hundreds of millions of refugees as coastal areas.
Swamp Miami is already slipping into the water.
There's already rapes.
No,
I know.
That will lead to without Miami.
The only upside of climate change is goodbye Florida.
Right?
We're never gonna have a 10,000 again.
Marco Rubio will be out of the Senate once Florida's off the map.
The real question is what will Nancy grace to for a job in Florida doesn't
exist?
Who will she have to complain about the Florida Twitter man account that's going
to happen in Florida and the Florida man.
Yeah,
account on Twitter.
I miss that.
That's a great account,
but you know what the database the Florida man has already achieved.
You could just go back in history and look at 2003,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
you'll have plenty of stuff to laughing about it.
We can reengineer Florida.
Florida will become like,
you know,
like back when they used to burn witches,
read back in the accounts of the Salem witch trials and you laugh.
That'll be Florida.
He'd be able to just look back at the time when we were half retarded now
Florida,
what was it about Florida?
Where were we thinking?
Bunch of factors.
Humidity is not good for consciousness.
It's a bunch of different things going on down there.
I think too much heat,
too much humidity is very bad for like critical thinking.
That's what I think.
Really.
I don't think it works.
I think you get hot.
You want to go on doors to fucking acs on you start blaming Jesus.
Shit gets weird when it gets really,
really hot.
I have all these relatives who've moved to Phoenix,
Arizona,
Diego,
Tucson,
and it's so funny to talk to them.
They're all from Chicago and they all move there cause uh,
you know,
Chicago,
it's cold.
I think Chicago's grade.
Uh,
I'd rather live in Chicago and in Seattle,
but I go to visit them every once in a while and I'm always like,
because this is such a shit hole.
Phoenix is such a shit hole in Tucson.
Oh,
it's awful.
And I always look at them say,
why do you live here?
And the thing that comes out of their mouths always,
I love the desert and I'm like,
you,
I never fucking in the desert.
You are in your air conditioned house.
You go to your air garage,
you get in your air conditioned car,
you drive to an air conditioned parking lot,
and you go to your air conditioned office.
You live in this air conditioned habit trail.
You're never in the Goddamn desert.
Yeah.
Anybody who loves the desert never goes to the desert.
And if you go to the desert,
you better go in there and fucking winter.
Okay,
go there in the summer,
you can die outside in a couple of hours.
Just wandering.
I know a guy died in the desert.
Evan Tanner for me.
UFC fighter.
Oh yeah.
He was a former UFC champion.
He was a a wonder lust,
sort of a guy who liked to walk in the desert one for a long,
he was one of those vision quest type characters.
Wanted to,
you know,
go on treks to find himself and to be alone in nature and decided to go on this
thing in the desert and got disoriented.
Couldn't find his camp losses.
Water died.
Yeah,
it's fucked.
But that's the desert.
That's the real desert.
That's not God Damn Phoenix parking lot.
You know that's not a fucking mall in Scottsdale.
I love the desert pitch.
You are not in the desert.
The desert eating fro Yo,
that desert is a horse climate with have Aleena's and fucking poisonous snakes
and Scorpions and shit.
That's the real desert.
It's a fucking rough world.
But Phoenix is,
that's why I like Chicago winter.
Why?
But you like Chicago so much.
Why do you like Chicago?
Cause it's not the desert.
It's cold as fuck in the winter though,
man.
It makes you appreciate it the summer.
And I agree with that.
It's a,
I live in Seattle where winter means it's 40 degrees and pouring rain.
So you're always sopping wet.
Chicago,
even when it's like 10 below,
you're dry and you dress for it,
you're dry.
And I think you're colder after a in 40 degrees soaking wet for six months.
Then you are in Chicago when it's 10 below for a couple of weeks.
Man.
I Dunno.
I think if you live in Chicago you might,
you might reassess that up in Chicago.
In Chicago.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well,
I don't know man.
Chicago's we're fucking brutal in the winter.
I love it there though.
It's great town,
but it is a great town.
Feel a smart,
cool people that have this weird Midwest thing going on.
Like good folks.
They have like this,
they're like intelligent worldly,
but they also have this sort of Midwest good folk thing going on that they don't
have the New York side and apartments can be had for less than the cost of two
kidneys.
Right.
As opposed to New York.
Yeah.
New York is pretty ridiculous.
But Chicago's got some serious issues with crime and violence to,
especially amongst black people.
The south side.
Yeah.
Unbelievable.
And,
uh,
when I was there,
um,
one of the guys who drove us around was a former cop and gave us some insight on
all of it and he said,
well,
it's like a power struggle thing.
They arrested a bunch of gang members thinking they were going to clean up the
situation and they only opened up a void that is being,
you know,
that they're battling to fill that they put these guys away and when they put
these guys away than other people were just trying to fight to battle to see who
takes the top position.
And growing up in Chicago,
the attitude was when I was a kid,
so long as the violence is contained to the south side,
so long as the violence is only hurting people of color,
it's not an issue for the city.
See,
I think I was just going to be an apocalypse.
It's going to be an apocalypse because of our attitude about four people.
It's about poor people are attitudes about poor people,
I think are the most shameful [inaudible]
and depressing aspects of modern society and culture that we're constantly
concerned with dealing with.
All these different things that are going on overseas and worrying about all
these,
the these different things that are happening in other countries and
accumulating natural resources and other countries.
But the number one resource that human beings have is humans,
human innovation and people.
And I've always said that if people were really concerned with strengthening
America,
the number one way to strengthen America is in make it so there's less losers,
right?
Well,
how do you do that?
You help out people that are disenfranchised and you help out people that have
been dealt the shitty hand in life,
being born in a poor neighborhood,
being born with no access to information,
preschool,
uh,
violence,
crime.
It's,
it's that,
it's that puritanical streak in American culture.
There is this thing that goes back to the very founding of the country that if
somebody is disadvantaged,
that they're divinely disadvantaged,
that God doesn't favor them.
They sort of being punished by God and by fate or whatever.
And the,
the,
our,
our society reflects that.
We treat people who are poor,
like shit.
We,
we continue to punish them.
We do everything we can possibly to make it worse for them.
And it's uh,
Paul Lang and it is so anti Christian.
It is so vicious.
I mean,
you look at the way,
uh,
even people who are imprisoned are screwed when they have to make a phone call
home.
It's some outrageous,
they get paid pennies to work in the,
you know,
some shit job in prison and then to make a phone call,
it's going to cost them two and a half bucks a minute to call their kid and talk
for five seconds.
And we,
we severed that relationship between incarcerated parent and child to the damage
that child and perpetuate that,
that system.
Do you think that it's a puritanical thing or do you think it's a human nature
thing that people who already are in a good position don't want to help someone
who's not in a good position?
I don't think you see it as a,
I mean there are certainly other societies,
other cultures,
other countries with huge disparities in income.
But I don't think in western industrialized countries,
you see it quite as starkly as you see it in the United States.
We have socialism for cars.
We totally subsidized roads.
We have socialism for airports.
Um,
but we don't have socialism for children and families and people who need
healthcare and people who need access to a decent food and decent housing.
We Bat,
we can socialize every other goddamn thing.
Socialize.
Yeah.
I think that's because everyone needs the roads.
Everyone needs the airports.
But you look at the people that everyone more and if you are not poor and you
don't care about them,
you know,
I am concentrating them on myself.
I'm worried about me.
I'm worried about getting my own thing.
I mean,
isn't that kind of the same thing is like,
but you have to share a world with,
you have to share a culture,
a city.
Um,
there's only so long a society can be in denial about the fact that we're all in
this together and there will be blow back if people,
the violence on the south side of Chicago,
um,
gang violence doesn't just claim gang members as victims.
It's spills out eventually and it will impact you whether you like it or not.
And there's only so many,
uh,
gated communicate
communities that you can hide in before the shit that you've been dealing out to
others or the culture,
the Sada societies with dealing with this,
uh,
comes for you to,
yeah,
no question about that.
I just wonder if the reason why we have this,
uh,
this need to socialize things like roads and airports,
but yet we don't concern ourselves with the people that are poor.
It's just that we don't have to,
it's just like the same sort of a thing where if you're doing well and you're
doing well in life,
like,
Hey,
I'm concentrating on me,
I'm going to push forward.
And then we have that convenient thing that a lot of people love to do.
That's really kind of disgusting where they,
they go,
hey,
you know,
a lot of people were born in poor neighborhoods and they make it,
I was born in a poor neighborhood and I did this and I did that.
I always called that argument.
The 90 year old smoker.
Oh yeah.
My grandfather smoked and lived to be 90 therefore it's not a carcinogen.
Like I know somebody who is poor who totally got it.
I got up so anybody can do it because that person can do it.
There.
There are structural disadvantages that consigned millions of people to poverty
with no hope of escape because you know one data 0.9 year old smoker who got
out.
Yeah.
That pull yourself up by your bootstraps argument is a really rough one because
there's some people that are born and they're so fucked up mentally by the time
they get to be well,
not only that,
just the psychology of of survival and dealing with a horrible neighborhood,
abusive family,
all the different things that you have to deal with.
If you're in a crime,
Britain environment,
by the time you get to 18,
19,
when you're an adult quote unquote,
you're so fucked up and you,
you have so much to deal with.
The idea that there's the only difference between you and someone else's
education and a job is preposterous because it's just the development as a human
being,
your,
your actual,
the structure of your mind of your psychology is so compromised by all the
things that you have.
It's a stress warps.
Mines.
And we have created a society that is built on stress,
economically,
epigenetic stress,
more warps minds in the womb.
You know,
they've shown that women who are really stressed out and in bad environments,
they developed children that have hair triggers.
You know,
I talked to Michael Irvin,
you know,
Michael Irvin,
the football player.
He uh,
works with a lot of disadvantaged kids and children that have problems with
violence and you know,
and giving them tools and uh,
you just coping mechanisms and what he was talking to me,
but we shared a long flight once to Sydney,
just by random luck.
He was on the same flight as me and we had a long conversation about it and it
was talking about how few people realize that the actual development of their
mind is different from the jump just because their mother grew up in a horrible
environment just cause they were being born and prepared for this environment of
incredible stress and danger.
And the idea that such a pull yourself up by your bootstraps,
what you need to do is just,
you know,
you've got to get it,
get an education.
You can go online and get an education with MIT like,
Oh fucking Christ man.
It's not that easy.
A few things we could do right off the bat to relieve all that kind of stress,
uh,
socialized medicine for all and not Obamacare.
Obamacare
is less evil than the system we had before,
but it's still kind of evil.
It's still going to leave millions of people uninsured.
Um,
17,000 people a year roughly are going to die,
uh,
under Obamacare because they don't have insurance leaves people uninsured,
um,
leaves people behind.
It's not universal,
the guaranteed minimum income.
All of these programs we have to address poverty.
We could bundle them all together,
eliminate them,
and give people all guaranteed minimum income,
which was a proposal that Richard Nixon made in the late sixties,
early seventies.
Guaranteed minimum income was so radical and socialist that a republican
president was talking about enacting it.
And just those two things,
absent a strong labor movement,
absent,
um,
decent jobs like those two things taken together would relieve a whole lot of
stress for a whole lot of working people and poor people.
And we'd have fewer kids born,
uh,
with those a hair trigger brains you're talking about?
Yeah,
the guaranteed minimums income.
I see the arguments against it.
I see what they're saying.
It's like they're worried that people get lazy and that people are just going to
take that minimum income and they're just gonna,
you know,
and they're not going to work hard.
Right.
Somebody gave you $75,000 a year.
Not that that would be the minimum income,
but if you had a whole 75 k lying around,
would you stop doing shit?
Some people would,
but doesn't.
Yeah,
I know people,
I've had people that worked for me who are lazy as fuck because they ended up
guaranteed income.
So I see the human nature aspect of it.
But the reality is like saying that the minimum wage shouldn't be $15 an hour.
Well it's asking someone to work for a fucking hour and only giving them $15 is
ridiculous.
And when you own something like Mcdonald's,
some gigantic multibillion dollar dollar corporation or even a franchise of a
multibillion dollar corporation,
the idea that that resource of a human being working for you is not worth $15 in
an hour when you're not making efficient use of that person then.
Well,
the,
the whole,
the problem with when we talk about minimum wage workers in fast food
establishments is we've gotten it into our heads somehow because of corporate
media.
I think because of the way we write about the labor movement or labor markets or
capital got,
it doesn't usually,
not my,
what I talk about and,
but I'd love to talk about it.
Um,
we've got into our heads that the guy who owns the Mcdonald's is giving that
person a job,
is doing that person a favor,
that they're lucky to have a job,
that they shouldn't look at their employer with anything but gratitude as if
their serfs is it this feudalism as opposed to that laborer is creating the
wealth.
That laborer is creating wealth for the,
for the Mcdonald's corporation,
for all of its shareholders.
And that Labor isn't just an employee who the corporation is doing a favor by
giving you a job.
That person creates wealth for the shareholders and has a claim,
a legitimate claim to a share of that wealth and a living wage share of that
wealth.
And when you look at Mcdonald's like billions of dollars of profit,
I did this on the back of a Napkin once just googling around Mcdonald with its
employees in the United States.
It means $7 billion
in profit last year.
They could pay each one of their employees and extra 15 or 20 k a year just by
returning $6 billion in profit to their shareholders one year instead of $7
billion that maybe a billion of that 7 billion rightfully belongs to Mcdonald's
employees that generated that wealth in the first place and not just to
Mcdonald's shareholders.
Why can't we have that conversation?
Well,
it's a good conversation for sure.
I think the the,
you know,
why did we,
the elements,
there's a lot of elements to what a human does when they work for,
I mean if you have a gigantic corporations is there's a huge,
it's a,
it's a huge thing with a lot of moving pieces and the moving pieces.
The organic moving piece since are human beings and some of the organic movement
pieces are CEOs and some of them are managers and there's this hierarchy as far
as like funds,
but when it gets down to the,
the,
the workers that are introduced,
the bottom line people that come in and they fill out an application and they
need a job.
The idea that paying them $15 an hour is outrageous.
It's fucking crazy.
Like what,
how do you expect these people to feed themselves?
How to expect these people to pay for food,
pay for housing.
You can't do that on less than $15 an hour.
You can barely do that on $15 an hour.
Part of the problem is the people who comment the,
the politicians are in their sixties and seventies,
most of them 50s and up,
um,
for their generation.
Those were jobs you had as teenagers.
Those were jobs that nobody worked in for years and years.
They weren't a job.
That wasn't a job working at Mcdonald's at an adult with the child had.
And everything has changed in the last 30 or 40 years since policymakers,
pundits,
people who edit newspapers were in the law,
that kind of,
that at that end of the labor market when they were just getting started.
So they have this attitude that this is not,
this doesn't,
this isn't supposed to be a living wage job because working at Mcdonald's is,
and something that an adult does all their lives in our new economy.
Uh,
you know,
Jay with nothing but shitty jobs available for people with college degrees,
working at Mcdonald's,
people with kids turns their families were getting the titles that $15 an hour
or up is completely justified.
And you know,
we used to like let people,
we used to pay a living wage,
a middle class wage to people who stood on assembly lines making cars doing the
same small action over and over again as the car moved on the assembly line.
And we say,
well,
here's an assembly line for Hamburgers for food.
Why should that person's labor be valued less?
And the Labor of the person working on a similar assembly line making a car?
Yeah.
Oh absolutely.
And the,
the idea that this shouldn't be a job that an adult has,
where the fuck are you?
You know,
it's a job.
W W who the fuck are you to say that this is isn't a job that someone should
have to support themselves?
This is an entry level.
The only job,
the,
you know,
we're talking about the economic revival.
We're talking about the recovery.
Most of the jobs that have been created are shitty minimum wage jobs with no
health insurance,
no pension plans,
nothing.
We have to make these jobs better if we're going to exist in an economy where
it's just people making hamburgers for each other and passing them around or
making drinks for each other a service we have to make
the service economy,
jobs,
living wage,
even middle class jobs.
We have to transform our economy.
Yeah,
no,
no argument there at all.
I think,
uh,
just compassion and generosity are two things that if you found out that a
corporation had and another corporation opposing corporational,
he could say if Wendy's proved to be super compassionate and generous and they,
they did that all the time when they support and then across the street was a
Mcdonald's who was doing the opposite.
I would always go to Wendy's.
I would go there right away.
I mean,
I would try to vote with my dollar if that was the situation.
I think if we find out who would do that.
So it needs to be the law.
Yeah.
Well,
I'm not saying that it only should be because people are compassionate,
but I think that there's not enough people that do it.
But I think if more people knew the benefits of that,
they probably would.
I think if more people were aware,
and I think more people are socially aware now than ever before.
I think more people are,
I mean,
just look at what people are getting in trouble for today that they would never
get in trouble for before socially.
Like we,
this Donald Sterling thing is a perfect example.
Guy Says he doesn't want his girlfriend to take pictures with black people.
That's it.
Fine if she fucks him.
Yeah,
fine.
And everybody,
by the way,
conveniently ignores that aspect of the conversation.
I do.
That's all I wrote about.
If it was the opposite,
imagine if anybody had a problem with that.
If you said,
hey listen,
you could take pictures of black people or you want,
just don't fuck them.
No one's saying anything.
They'd be like,
well,
this is an unfortunate conversation that was captured on video or recording,
whether,
you know,
between some sad man and his girlfriend,
old man,
old man with it,
turns out Alzheimer's.
Now he's got,
you know,
they've diagnosed him with Alzheimer's.
He's an old fuck,
he's 82 years old.
The nobody rides for free.
You know,
this meat wagon that you're on,
it's eventually going to fall apart.
And when you're 82 begging to fuck some 20 year old,
you've got a buyer for robberies and Bentley's and you've got to ask her not to
take patients with black people because you're,
you're falling apart.
You know,
he's an old dude.
But the outrage and the,
the movement against him and you know,
and a lot of it's posturing.
The NBA finding him two and a half million dollars,
the highest amount banning him for life because he doesn't want his girlfriend
taking pictures of black people.
It's fucking preposterous.
It's all ridiculous.
But what I like about it is a stand,
it's a stand,
a stand about the accepted social realities of our world today.
And that we can communicate that we don't like racism in a way that's never been
able to,
we communicate that we don't like racism and then we say we have solved racism
because we drove Donald sterling out of the NBA.
Meanwhile,
we don't address the social inequities that are with the racism so deeply
encoded into,
uh,
our society,
our politics,
like we've solved the Donald Sterling problem.
What about all these African American kids trapped in Shitty,
Shitty,
shitty schools on the south side of Chicago?
What about efforts to disenfranchise millions of people of Color and young
people,
uh,
efforts being led by Republicans?
It's almost as if the Donald Sterling freak out and all this desire to pay
attention to it and then take satisfaction from the resolution of it is to just
meant to distract us or in a way functions to distract us from the systemic
racism that still plagues our society.
That the much harder things to solve so we don't solve them.
We just sort of ignore them.
We are disenfranchising African American voters all over this country with the
gutting of the voting rights act by the Supreme Court with the Supreme Court did
is so much,
arguably worse and more racist and he's going to have more consequences for more
African American people than what Donald Sterling did.
Asshole old fuck with Alzheimer's puts foot in mouth and the whole country stops
to fix that.
Right?
Nobody would rest until Donald Sterling was,
was driven out.
And the Supreme Court,
that's the voting rights act and disenfranchise millions of African American
voters all over the south.
Nobody gives a fuck.
Well,
I don't think it's that,
and I certainly don't think that anybody thinks we fixed racism.
I think that it's a gossipy thing and people love gossip and they caught an old
man doing something he's not supposed to be.
And part of the salaciousness of it is that it's on a recording.
He didn't know it's being recorded and the girlfriend is young and he's old.
And I don't think anybody's claiming that we fixed racism because we caught this
dude.
But I think that what we're seeing now,
because of the fact that any credit,
but he can be recorded at any point in time to say that what we're seeing now is
we're seeing this access to information that we were talking about earlier,
that things are getting very weird.
The lines between privacy and public are getting very weird and we're also
seeing that there's a certain amount of people that have a reaction to what we
deem to be a racist thing,
a racist,
a racist act.
What he did and were upset about it.
I don't think it absolves the supreme quarter that I think people conveniently
ignore the supreme court because it's confusing at what we choose to get upset
about,
like what we choose to pay attention to
people in the wake of Donald Sterling saying,
Oh,
this is evidence of the progress we've made,
but I think it is evidence of the progress that we've made.
What about the evidence?
The much greater and weightier evidence of the have moving backwards on voting
rights for people of Color?
I don't think they're mutually exclusive.
I think that's true.
That is true that there's,
they can both happen simultaneously,
but the conversation about sterling was so much louder,
longer and more impassioned on all parts.
Then the conversation about voter rights,
he didn't understand that sterling thing is it's gossip and that's why he would
bold.
It's a story as old as time
young woman who's young and hot and he fucks her for money,
but look at the way people understand it.
People understand it to mean we've made this tremendous progress on issues of
race in our country and our culture and our politics and our media and in
actuality the real story is we're going backwards fast and gutting Donald
Sterling on primetime.
Television doesn't change that.
I think socially it does.
I think socially it makes people a little bit more aware of the that people have
an intolerance for race or culture and society can do blatantly racist shit.
No,
it's not that I shoot the supreme court thing.
I say,
I did disagree with you on this because don't think the supreme court thing is,
I think it's ignored first of all by the mainstream media because people tend to
blank out.
When you talk about the Supreme Court,
there's a certain amount of people that are aware and intelligent and concerned
and active in voting and all these,
you know,
various laws that get passed that are very detrimental to the way we live our
lives and racist they,
they're aware of them.
And there's plenty of websites that cover these things,
but I think mainstream news,
whether it's Fox News,
whether it's CNN or they ignore it,
and one of the reasons why they ignore it cause it's the goddamn ratings killer.
Cause most people don't understand how laws are created and they don't
understand what,
what happens when it comes to the Supreme Court and the politics and the Senate
and Congress.
It's all very confusing and they zone out when that shit goes on.
And it is the responsibility of the media to make the real story be exciting,
sexy one that that's where it gets carried.
You look his way.
We're all media in January in this or is it,
is it Jews distribution?
January is going to come around and we're all going to filleted ourselves
celebrating Martin Luther King Day and wonderful and awesome.
That is meanwhile what Martin Luther King fought for a wasn't just,
you know,
the civil rights movement wasn't just about,
uh,
you know,
eating lunch at the Woolworth's counter.
It was about registering people to vote.
It was about a poll taxes and pull tests.
Um,
and the disenfranchisement of African American voters all through the south.
We are back there.
We are back to that disenfranchised what he fought against.
It makes me think way back to argue about this.
Yeah,
it's funny,
right?
The voting rights act,
the gutting of the voting rights act,
the day after the voting rights act was gutted.
All these states that had,
uh,
voter ID laws that disenfranchise primarily people of Color,
um,
that were on hold because there were being contested in court by the federal
government immediately implemented that.
For folks who don't know.
Explain what it means.
Explain voter ID laws,
voter ID laws to combat vote fraud,
of which there is no evidence that there's any sort of vote fraud going on,
any form of courses.
And vote fraud means you show up and vote,
uh,
at a polling place pretending to be someone you're not.
That's vote fraud.
You can register to vote.
Uh,
Mickey Mouse can registered about Mickey mouse can't show up to vote,
right?
So somebody is going to show up,
pretend to be Joe Rogan and,
and vote in your place,
right?
That doesn't happen to throw elections.
It doesn't happen.
Voter ID laws are ostensibly designed to stop this thing that doesn't happen,
which is voter fraud.
And it requires someone to have a photo,
a government issued photo identification,
which a lot of people,
particularly poor people,
people of color don't have.
They're registered to vote.
They have addresses,
they have,
uh,
you know,
bills that come to their house with their names and their addresses.
And if they can prove that they're them,
they don't have a driver's license.
And so people who are in their nineties people are in their eighties African
Americans in the south who have been voting since the 60s since they won the
right to vote in the south,
are showing up the Poles being turned away because they don't have a driver's
license.
Well,
they don't drive and the same governments or the same state governments that are
instituting many of these voter id laws are closing voter id places where voters
can identification
or Eric shutting down.
DMV branches are making it harder to get the ID that you need to vote.
They're just raising the bar,
make it more and more difficult,
particularly for poor people,
African American people,
young people to vote.
And this is going on and this is blatantly racist and it is going on while the
Donald Sterling thing is going on and all we can talk about it.
Donald Sterling,
well,
this was sort of a highlighted by the Al Gore Administration where the Al Gore
campaign,
when he was running for president and they,
they did this all throughout Florida,
did through this all throughout the south.
They shut people out.
A lot of people purge the voter rolls.
They keep doing it.
They're doing it in Florida before 2012 purging the voter roles and done
specifically to try to keep Democrats for voting.
And Yeah,
weirdly,
when you looked at who is being purged,
a poor precincts,
precincts that had democrats,
people of color,
and also went on the same time the Diebold voting scandal was going on where the
hacking democracy documentary was released,
where they showed that not only are these Diebold electronic voting machines
hackable,
but they're engineered to be hackable,
engineered to have a third party access.
Everything should change.
Everything should be paid for about you think.
Yeah.
And vote by mail,
which is what we have in Washington state.
Everything's vote by mail.
We have no polling places.
You've got,
you've registered to vote,
you get your ballot in the mail,
it comes to your house,
you fill it out,
he put it back in the mail.
Do you think people should be able to vote online if there was a way to make it
secure and there should be a way to make it secure?
Peter,
we've made banking secure online.
Uh,
I do think there should be a way to vote.
I'm like,
but I'm,
but,
but that like,
you know,
somebody could hack that somebody hacked target somebody if they've got online
voting pardon?
Think they can hack money.
I mean they can hack anything.
I mean,
if that's where worries about we,
they certainly can hack paper voting.
I mean,
they did that all the hanging chads.
Remember that?
Yeah.
And I mean that's the butterfly ballot in 2000 that gave us George W.
Bush for president.
Yeah.
I mean there was a lot of shit that they've done without a doubt.
I mean,
how many bags of fucking voter receipts have gone missing throughout the years?
People have had paper voting.
I mean,
how many,
how many people have hidden things or change things or move things around?
That's essentially the same as hacking.
It's actually probably less traceable than electronic hacking could be if done
correctly,
through a very secure way.
What are the same way that banking stuff?
One of the ways you can,
uh,
prevent hacking the vote at Washington state where we have a main all male in it
is you can track your vote online that you,
uh,
you send in your ballot.
Um,
did they send it to you?
You send it back and then there's a website you can go to and it will indicate
when your ballot has been received and when your ballot has been counted.
Hmm.
That's a good idea.
I mean,
that doesn't,
so that if you vote and you feel like your balance been misplaced,
you feel like your ballot may have been trashed or you know,
you,
you worry that somebody could be breaking in and stealing ballots and throwing
them away.
You can go and make sure that your ballot was processed and counted so that if
your belt went missing,
you can vote again.
You can go down to the county and do a provisional ballot.
Well,
that's a great idea.
I mean,
I think that that if,
if that's implemented nationwide and done and some sort of an electronic way,
I mean we can have a radical shifts in the way people are elected.
But like Bill Maher said last week on a real time,
Republicans,
when when people don't vote,
they want to drive the boat down.
And so you have one party that is that self interest lies in not getting more
people to vote.
That's why they're shutting down early voting stations.
That's why they're closing polling places in states controlled by the Republican
party because they want fewer people to vote.
It would be great if we had a universal,
uh,
or an Australian system where voting is mandatory.
You pay a 10 buck fine.
If you don't want to vote,
you don't have to vote to 10 bucks,
fine or something.
It's a monetary Ding if you don't vote in Australia.
But if everybody voted,
we would have gun control.
Well
that should be a way.
If,
um,
if you could,
no,
everyone voted,
we'd have health care,
we'd have national healthcare.
All of these things are popular with average voters who don't vote because
they're not motivated
be a way where if you don't vote,
you have less access to something.
If you only could access online porn after voting,
everybody would fucking about,
well it'd be interesting at least find out where people's priorities lie.
But I think if you,
if you made it set up so that there was some sort of a social,
a price to pay,
you know,
like maybe there was,
didn't have access to national parks.
He didn't have access to certain things.
If you didn't vote like your,
your,
your lack of participation.
Yes.
That runs up against the first amendment because there's a,
there's an argument to be made that not voting itself as a form of speech,
that it's to reject either all the candidates who are on offer it to reject the
system itself and to advocate by refusing to participate some other form of
government.
Uh,
and so you know that that's not,
that can't be implemented.
Something like punishment because of the first amendment punishment for not
voting because uh,
it's totally legit argument to make that non voting as a form of speech.
Well,
there's also a big problem with the voting system itself.
The two party system is inherently flawed and not only that,
you have both sides being supported by the same corporations left and right,
and we need personal
waystation.
Until we have that,
we're going to have this corporate is democracy that's a little fucked.
You know,
we seem to
manage your,
your hopefulness for the survival of the species on the planet.
I have that sort of hopefulness for our democracy and the way it sort of Koreans
from near disaster to near disaster and then writes itself.
Um,
I think our democracy is,
uh,
perhaps,
um,
healthier,
uh,
and likely to survive than the planet itself.
I think it's in the plan,
in our democracy,
the earth that our culture and society depends on it.
Your live is less likely to,
I think it's a puppet show.
I think that what we're dealing with now is massive corporations that have
incredible influence,
that pay politicians to support their causes.
And that's what,
that's what we call voting.
We have two choices,
but strong choice in the left,
one strong choice in the right,
both of them in many ways are supported by the same entrance.
That's ridiculous.
That's not voting.
I mean,
that's just,
it's,
it's a false choice,
which why some people don't
vote and that is protected speech to not vote.
But there are certain issues,
social issues that the left tends to favor that the right ignores.
And there's certain issues that the right tends to favor and the left ignore or
opposes,
it gets weird,
man.
It gets weird because people love to be in a group.
They love to be on a team.
They love to be,
you know,
whatever it is,
whether it's,
uh,
you know,
people that,
uh,
drive Chevy's,
they love to be in a group of other Chevy owners.
You know,
they love it.
If they feel that camaraderie,
they can feel like a team.
I'm a parent,
you know,
my kids careening towards 18.
And uh,
you know,
you talk about tribalism,
family identity that like you from a Republican family.
And I'd always hear that and I wouldn't,
I never quite understood it,
but I get it now because I say to my,
you know,
I've said to my son,
when you're 18,
you're registered to vote.
If you're still living in this house,
you're registered to vote and God help you if you vote Republican,
this is,
why would you say that though?
It would if he,
he has different opinions and she allowed to have different opinions.
He's allowed to have different opinions if he's paying his own rent and over
food.
Oh God,
not,
I'm going to monitor his vote or anything.
And it's like joking,
like,
I'll kill you if you voted Republican.
I'm not going to like a hover over him as he boats.
But you know,
families do impart a certain,
uh,
political identity,
not just a religious identity,
your cultural identity.
And we're,
we're really doing that to our code.
I think that socially though,
people don't like that.
When you suppress.
Like there's a school that,
uh,
one of my daughter's friends goes to where you can't have different color hair.
You know?
Uh,
like if you,
if you dry dye your hair color,
that's not natural.
They freak out at you.
They won't let you do it.
And I'm like,
that's ridiculous.
Because then if you tell a girl that you can't have pink hair,
green hair,
tell boy he can't dye his hair purple.
They're going to fucking hate you.
Like who are you?
What difference does it make?
I don't have any hair.
How about that?
You know,
what difference does it make?
I mean,
am I allowed to,
I have to wear a wig to being your fucking school.
Why does the school have that policy?
They're assholes.
They're a bunch of old ass holes that grew up without the internet probably.
They set all these rules.
They want people to behave a certain way.
Why do they make you put your fucking seat backup when you're landing a plane?
Is someone going to die?
It's bullshit.
It's nonsense.
It's a control issue.
It doesn't have any bearing whatsoever on safety bearing on safety to seeping
up.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Cause it makes it easier for people to get out of their aisle in a hurry.
Like if the seats are all winky Janky,
I got for you to evacuate the plane.
That fucking plane goes down.
It ain't gonna matter.
It does matter.
Look at the plane that landed in the Hudson and everybody had to get the hustle
out of a ticket on the wings as it sank.
There's that plane crash.
Oh God.
Where was it?
Where the poor kids got run over by fire trucks and then they were running out
of the plane after crashing.
Most people got off that plane.
Some people burned to death on that plan because they didn't,
they couldn't get off it in time.
Partly because some people were getting their more bags and trying to get their
bags as they evacuated the planet that you don't want.
You know,
maybe some people were,
you know,
Americans are big.
Maybe some people were wedged behind.
That's a size of shaky janky seats in the first class.
[inaudible] this fucking ain't gonna do shit.
Does the difference between getting out God goddamn gap and the eye.
You've been in coach on United lately.
Holy Crap.
Yeah.
I was in coach on the,
I did a month ago.
Floss your teeth with the hair of the person sitting in front of you.
Well I had my computer open and the guy in front of me sat back and my computer
shut like it was on the tray.
The guy put his seat back and it literally closed the computer.
I couldn't,
I had to like scoot back and push it forward like this.
If we had,
if we had a real democracy we would have a referendum on non declining nine non
reclining seats.
Like every seat set to a certain pitch and no up and down,
no reclining bullshit,
no passive aggressive game playing on airplanes anymore apartment.
Right.
So maybe the back seat back thing doesn't work.
That argument doesn't work as far as United goes,
but the reason why people tell people they can't have color hair is because
they're trying to control them and we try to control people.
They rebound.
You grew up Catholic?
I was Catholic too.
For a little bit.
And uh,
when I was a kid,
we always knew that Catholic girls were the biggest sluts and the reason why
Catholic girls are the biggest slap to my mother and my sister's honor.
Asthma,
not slut shaming.
But when you suppress people,
when you suppress people like that,
we don't think about it.
Banana,
they fucking go crazy.
People don't like other people telling them what to do.
They go bananas.
They don't like it.
It's done.
It's not natural.
It's not healthy.
And when they can look at it objectively and go,
what fucking difference does it make?
If my hair is pink,
your hair could be pink and you could be a gun damn scientist that saves the
world.
It does not matter what call your fucking hair is.
Well,
why do you send your kid bear?
No,
I don't.
Oh,
no,
no.
It's one of my daughter's friends.
Oh,
no,
no.
I thought you sent your no,
no,
no.
I think it's,
it's,
it's just a function of people who they want control and they don't worry about
the repercussions of that control.
You know,
and I think that Republicans tend to be more in that camp,
but they tend to be more in the camp of people who want control.
They tend to be more in the camp for your change.
They want ties.
They want you to,
you know,
wear loafers,
stay in line.
They don't want you to be gay.
They don't want you to be weird.
They don't want you to be,
you know,
they don't want you to have tattoos.
They don't mind if you're gay.
You just have to be closeted.
Yeah,
that's,
that's it.
That's a real weird one,
isn't it?
What did you think about the whole thing that was going on during the Bush
administration when Jeff Gannon was in the White House,
but he's an embedded reporter for folks who don't know.
It was a guy who would,
not only was he a gay prostitute,
but he ran a gay prostitute website and he would be an embedded reporter and he
would lobbed softballs at the president.
Mr President.
Awesome.
Are you today?
How are you?
Awesome.
Are the yesterday and do you believe that we all summer tomorrow than you are
today?
My favorite one is when are these Democrats going to come to realize how
ridiculous their ideas are?
Like it was literally,
that was like one of his questions.
He would throw these stupid fucking softball back story to that that we are
never going to get that's like locked up in some safe.
Oh yeah.
He got credentialed who he knew in the White House.
How he got all tied into that dude that was chasing kind of star.
It was all tied into him.
And uh,
who's the guy who,
uh,
the,
the main engineer guy who got Bush office and he,
Karl Rove.
Yeah.
Karl Rove is notoriously closeted,
right.
Isn't supposedly allegedly never suck mine tech.
Well you should ask.
I bet he would say everything's my Dick won't do and call rose mouth would be
really high on the list,
but it's still,
he's never seen some sort of a glory hit thing.
Laurie whole thing going on that would be an in glory,
this whole,
it's somebody he had spent the night at the White House and more than one
occasion.
So there's some inherent weirdness involved in that guy to have sex in the White
House.
But not only that,
they also,
like when you,
I always say if you look at people that are trying to like actively trying to
oppose gay marriage,
you know,
actively trying to pose gay relationships,
trying to stop them almost always or something gay going
journalizing and internal conflict.
When you look at somebody like Marcus Bachmann who yes,
Michele Bachmann's husband show Bachmann's husband who is pray the gay away who
is gay or Sound Asleep on the sofa than I am with a my Dick in my husband's ass.
That man is on fire.
Right.
And we can all see it.
And you know,
I don't know if he's actually gay or not,
but he certainly plays one on TV and you and his whole practice,
part of his practice is devoted to x gay therapy to talking other people out of
what he talked himself out of being.
There's a lot of rage that fuels the anti gay movement and its people by the
people who say being gay is a choice.
They saying sexual orientation as a choice because they chose not to be gay.
They chose not to come out and identify as gay.
They are gay and they keep getting out at Ted Haggard,
George Recurs.
There's all these examples of prominent people in the anti gay right on the x
game movement itself.
Like George Recurs who get caught with Dicks of course because they've
externalize this internal conflict.
I would love,
you know as somebody I write to a lot of like young people and it would be so
great if being rabidly homophobic became associated with being gay.
I think it is because,
because there's like there's homophobia out there like kids don't want anyone to
think they're gay.
So I say to these like high school and college age kids I sometimes talk to,
if you don't want anyone to think you're gay,
don't be anti gay.
Cause that makes people think you're gay.
Like if you don't,
if being gay being thought of as game makes you uncomfortable and squeaks you
out cause gay is Nikki,
then you better be cool with the gays.
Don't you think that's already the case though?
I think it's catching on but not entirely the case with high school,
college age kids still think homophobia,
the paranoia amongst any smart kids,
it is any smart kit,
it's getting battle sideways like well what are you so angry about?
Dude I did it and there's really quickly before we go on and their science here
that they have wired up with a penis amount or I can never say this word.
It's basically a glass tube.
You stick somebody sticking and you show them porn and it measures very subtle
blood flow changes to the deck and hardens and you show they took homophobes,
they measure these people.
Dot Tongue and measurement for their homophobia and they showed these guys gay
porn and they all got boners.
So like homophobia correlates very strongly with gay desire and arousal.
Yeah.
Isn't it amazing that homophobes they actually
agreed to sign up for that.
You might not be getting like the most unbiased fucking,
that group might be a mess.
I think we need to look at the research methodology,
but I do believe they didn't say we need homophobes for this study where we're
going to see if you're actually fags or not.
They didn't recruit,
cry quite bad night.
I had a joke in my last special that if you hate gay marriage is one of two
reasons.
Either you're really dumb or you secretly worried that Dick's are delicious.
The only two possibilities.
Otherwise,
why would you give a fuck?
It's like this guy,
this duck dynasty guy who always like,
I don't get it.
You know I don't get why man,
when you don't have to get everything like you don't.
I don't get yellow cars.
I don't get dubstep.
Certainly movies,
but I'm not trying to pass a constitutional amendment banning it.
That's the diff like I don't care if you don't get it,
it's not for you.
Like there are things that aren't for me and that's fine.
I like Rick Perry the other days comparing homosexuality to alcoholism because
you,
everybody knows like what does he Rick Perry telling us about himself?
Because you say to somebody who are alcoholic and they say,
Oh,
I just have a couple of drinks before dinner.
I'm not an alcoholic.
Like,
okay,
ready care.
He really,
yeah,
you're acquainted homosexuality now.
Awesome.
So as you basically saying,
you know,
you go to repair,
he like,
are you gay?
No,
I have a couple of dicks before dinner.
I'm not gay.
Or that's how it would work in.
They're exactly the same.
That's hilarious.
Rick Perry,
that guy was so silly.
He was one of my favorite guys ever debating when he got to that point where he
didn't remember what he was talking about.
He's like,
ah,
I don't remember the rest.
And he had the meltdown and that speech in Vermont where they gave him the maple
syrup and then he just kind of lost it.
My favorite thing about that though was the,
the whole country coming to the conclusion that this man,
Rick Perry was too stupid to be president,
but just stupid enough to be governor of Texas.
He needs to go home and keep on being governor of Texas cause he's not,
you can't be too stupid to be governor of Texas as we learned in 2000 Texas.
Didn't bother.
You know,
they,
they didn't care.
It didn't bother them whatsoever that he was all stupid shit,
fucking forgetting things.
But he's a leader.
He's a good man.
He represents my Christian values.
That's all I care about.
I mean,
how hard is it to be the Goddamn governor?
What are you going to do?
Keep the Mexicans out,
make sure I keep my guns.
I don't need a lot of government.
That's the,
I don't need a lot of government argument is fascinating,
I think from the same people who are calling for more government patrols of the
border.
Yeah.
And more deportations.
How do you do that without more government?
What do I need that kind of calling for the government to stop women from having
abortions kind of government.
They want to shrink government.
So it's just small enough to jam up every woman's Twat.
Then government will be the perfect size.
That's Jesus government.
This is a different kinds of government that's in the Bible,
son.
Imagine if people had the same reactions to seafood that they do to gay marriage
or gay love,
because in the Bible like seafood,
shellfish,
it's very fucking bad for you.
They don't want it.
So shellfish shouldn't pigs shrimp as many references more than gay marriage,
more than gay sex,
right wing fundamentalist Christians will tell you that,
you know,
that was the old law and Jesus negated it.
Now we have the new law,
but the New Testament support slavery,
uh,
obey your master as you would Christ.
The New Testament condemns Jesus and his own word condemns a divorce.
And anybody who is divorces,
his wife is committing adultery.
Um,
and you don't have a big mass Christian movement in this country to ban divorce,
just to attack gay people want to get married.
Yeah,
that would be the best way.
If you really wanted to prove the sanctity of marriage and divorce and divorce
and band Vegas chapels ones,
he can go in when you're fucking,
how about a three strikes?
You're out rule like get married three times,
but that's like Newt Gingrich.
This is your last one.
You fuck this one up nude and no more.
How many times has he been married?
Three.
I can't trust the people that that fat,
you're lazy.
If you get that fat and you're trying to be a leader like that.
Chris Christie guy like I have a lot of fat friends and they're great,
but they're lazy.
You can't run things.
You have to any personal demons and people could say,
oh,
you're fat shaming,
your fat shaming.
Look man,
what happens when you get a fucking a lap band?
What's going on there?
They're stopping you from consuming food.
They're not.
They're not really fixing anything other than they've making your stomach
smaller.
There's a lot of laziness involved in that argument.
It's a very silly,
silly argument.
And when you've got a big fat mutton face like Newt Gingrich,
because you're lazy,
you're a lazy person,
maybe you enjoy food.
You know,
I get in trouble sometimes with the fat acceptance movement because I believe,
and I have said,
and this gets called cat phobic,
that there is a relationship between how much you eat,
how much you move,
and how big you are.
I don't have any problem with people who are contented whatever size they want
to be.
I just have a problem with ims to pretend that there's no relationship between
consumption,
movement and size,
all this shit.
And Chris Christie,
if I said it,
if somebody had said before Chris Christie got his lap band that he has a food
problem,
that there's food issues.
That's why he's so big.
You would have been attacked by the fat acceptance Movement for food shaming him
or judging him.
And it's not always about food.
But then the intervention gets between Chris Christie and food and he starts
losing weight.
So clearly there was a food problem,
the intervention.
So there are people who aren't,
you know how he get a lap band.
He got a bariatric surgery.
That's why he's losing so much weight and lost like a year and a half ago.
I don't pay attention to him running up running for,
he's going to win.
You know,
before the bridge scandal came along and fucked him.
He was gonna run for presidency.
Him Lose weight to run for president fat acceptance,
the fat acceptance movement.
I except fat people as friends.
I accept him and all that.
But there's a reason why you're overweight and whatever it is,
whether it's hormonal,
whether it's,
you know,
when you have a slow metabolism,
whatever it is,
there's food that comes into your body and that's what makes you overweight.
I mean that it's really that simple.
But you know,
there's a lot of new research,
like you were saying that,
you know,
people in utero whose parents are stressed that can have an impact on their
brain.
There's also evidence that shows that there's a relationship between in utero
stuff.
And I can't off the top of my head,
call it up.
I could look it up.
Um,
that can have an impact on somebody's metabolism and um,
the obedience,
the third propensity to being obese,
there are cultural factors.
I think there's societal factors,
but there's also,
there are also medical and genetic factors at play as well.
Sometimes
people will hide behind the medical genetic factors and claim that the entire
obesity epidemic is about some sort of mass,
uh,
morphing,
um,
uh,
genetic.
Uh,
what's the word?
Darwinism mutation.
Um,
and we're all suddenly genetically predisposed in a way that we weren't before.
But there are genetic factors at play and not just a personal factor.
There's a personal factors at play as far as metabolism goes.
It's some people consume food is digested quicker,
but the reality is what is the lap band doing with the lap band is doing,
is interfering with your ability to consume.
So if you just had the same discipline that the lap band provides you with
essentially what it's doing,
the lap band is enforcing a discipline and that discipline has now you don't
have a choice to whether or not you eat smaller portions.
You're being forced to eat smaller portions because your stomach is smaller.
But if somebody doesn't want to get the lap band,
if somebody who's happy at whatever size they are,
I don't judge them.
I don't judge them either.
But I do judge them.
And this is why judge them.
I just,
well I don't judge them as a human being,
but I judge them.
If you want to be a person who is in control,
if you want to be a person who is in power,
when someone runs for office,
you have to judge their character.
You have to judge there will,
you have to judge their discipline.
See,
I don't have any discipline.
It's about power.
Well,
yeah.
Well I mean you think a person without discipline cannot be a person who leads
the person who leads should be a person that has all their ducks in a row.
I think it's,
there's some,
maybe there's something here also about class because when you think about,
uh,
you know,
in societies where food is scarce,
it's better to be bigger.
That larger is more attractive because it says something about your,
your power.
It says something about your access to resources and now in,
you know,
society's swimming in cheap calories.
If you are not obese,
it says something about your power.
Again,
it says that you are able to resist this,
that you have that strength to resist it perhaps,
and not to succumb to all these cheap and easy calories that are everywhere.
So I think what you're tapping into there when you say not a leader is you're
looking for people who are powerful and it is now,
uh,
you know,
slimness is associated with higher socioeconomic classes and higher education
levels.
And so I think that's what you're,
that's informing your opinion perhaps subconsciously about bigger people is that
obesity is associated with,
uh,
the underclass.
That's not what I'm saying with Chris Christie by far.
He's obviously has enough money to eat healthy.
That's ridiculous.
That guy can eat salads all day if he wants to.
Nothing stopping him economically from any healthy food.
He's a fat fuck cause he's lazy because he likes to shove things in his Gordon,
who cares?
What did
people talk?
If you're a wealthy person,
if you're a wealthy person and you choose to eat food that makes you obese,
what's going on there?
You're making a choice.
Now you can make choices all day to smoke cigarettes and drink booze,
to do unhealthy things to at all sorts of things.
The lie in the Sun,
who cares?
But when you become a person that's trying get into a position of leadership,
what is a leader?
A person who you look up to,
they say,
that guy has got his stuff in order.
That woman is clearly a person who is exceptional.
She thinks clearly she's disciplined,
she's compassionate,
she's nice,
and she's a person that I can be inspired to do support.
Can't be inspired by that.
When you're a big fat file,
do you support Clinton?
I support the lesser of two evils.
I met Clinton in the,
when he was fat and nineties when he was jogging big club soda.
So why not Christie?
Because look who was up against Luke who Clinton was up against.
I mean look at,
look at Bush senior.
Look at it.
If it was a wash,
if it was,
if there was not a time for the difference between,
uh,
George Hw Bush and a William Jefferson Clinton,
you would have voted for George w just on being the skinnier of the two.
If it was,
well,
you'd have to have a different George h w well,
yeah,
just totally different human plead equal candidates.
You have to flip a coin to decide.
One is skinny,
one is before it gets a fat.
Well,
Clinton was not fat when he was running for president.
He became fat and I'm sure that pressure and a lot of the,
the,
I mean he was obviously sexually kinda gluttonous,
you know,
he said,
yeah man,
have big appetites.
One of the reasons why a guy like that gets into office in the first place,
it's because they,
they want what they want to JFK man of appetites,
sexual appetites,
Franklin Delano Roosevelt,
the big appetites.
But I think Clinton's benefits where that is extremely intelligent,
that he had a grasp of foreign policy that he had this way of speaking that was
very inspiring.
There was a lot of very,
very positive things about Clinton.
I think he's a brilliant,
brilliant man.
I think that's without question,
but I think he himself recognized that he had issues with his body and then he
became a vegetarian or Vegan or Vegan hovers supposed to say that it's supposed
to be.
Yeah.
I mean it's top,
you know,
weight.
When he was jogging all the time,
it's still eating cheeseburgers.
I mean,
he was,
it was kind of a joke,
right?
I mean it was kind of a funny thing,
but I think that that was constantly picked on for a reason.
I mean,
it was,
it was something that was laughed at and mocked for reason.
It's not that you should mock everyone who's fat everywhere you go,
but I think when you put yourself in a position where you're saying,
I want to be a leader,
I want to be the person who runs things,
check,
check me out.
[inaudible]
wait,
disqualifies him.
At least for you.
Partially because of the discipline thing.
Clinton's wait,
humanized him.
Otherwise,
he was this road scholar,
governor of a state in his very early in life,
kind of political automaton.
And there was something about Clinton's appetites and I think for food and for
Pussy,
which we all knew about and every people kind of had heard Bimbo eruptions and
shit before.
Uh,
the Bimbo eruptions actually erupted.
That made him feel like a human being and not just a political machine,
not just a robot.
And I think people voted for Clinton in part because of his appetites maybe.
I think certainly people like people that are soft,
you know,
like
don't make them feel uncomfortable.
Like someone,
if you get some Uber Marsh who's running for office and he's fucking running up
hills every day with a weight vest on and he's a fucking animal in the gym and
you know,
he has strict discipline.
He doesn't put salt on his food.
No fat in his diet,
drinks only water.
That'll make it a little uncomfortable.
Yeah.
Like this guy is like,
he's like so driven and disciplined and crazy.
He might be a psychopath,
might be something wrong with his eye.
There's no human eye.
He doesn't like cake.
A guy who doesn't like cake.
I can't,
I can't get behind.
I like cake too.
But look,
it's easy for me to stay thin.
I've been involved in exercise my entire life.
I'm very biased when it comes to when I talk about weights,
but when I see someone who's just blatantly obese and they want to run for
president or they want to run for office or there they want to put themselves in
a position of leadership,
you have to judge that
leadership is about ideas and leadership.
If there was a leader who was morbidly obese and supported,
uh,
you know,
a revived labor movement and health care for all and urban policies and mass
transit and doing,
addressing,
not just addressing but fucking doing something about climate change,
I would vote for that obese candidate over some shredded idiot who took the
opposite position on it.
Right?
But that's a manufactured argument because who's saying that the other guy has
to be like that you have to have all these great qualities and be fat.
But if they have all these great qualities and be fat,
that fat part is the only thing that's wrong with them.
That's great.
Yeah,
that's wonderful.
But if you have someone who is like a normal human being that has all sorts of
issue,
oh there is though.
It's unhealthy if someone's living so smoking.
So smoking is a huge flaw.
Obama,
Obama smokes.
I think it's a huge flaw.
I think it's a huge flaws.
You vote for him?
I voted for,
I voted for him because I felt like what are the what's,
what's the possibility of Sarah Pailin becoming president?
What's the possible?
Was He only reason?
What's the Pailin?
Well,
Mccain was,
he's got a lot of issues.
Talk about you.
You were saying,
well he's really old and really,
and second of all,
look the,
you were just saying the judge
two evils argument.
I thought Obama was going to be way different than what he is in the first
place.
I have a lot of friends who smoke.
I mean,
I'm not saying there's anything wrong with smoking.
It's an easy thing to get caught up in.
It's an easy thing to catch you.
And the next thing you know,
you can't get rid of it.
You're addicted to it.
But it is a flaw.
It's absolutely a flaw.
And when you're judging leaders,
look,
I have flaws.
I'm sure you have floss.
Human beings have flaws,
but that's a real one.
That's a real one.
And I was sucking on cancer sticks.
There's no benefit.
Nobody hates smoking more than I do.
I've never smoked.
And I've had a lit cigarette in my hand.
I think it's disgusting.
Okay,
well let's look at it this way.
If you were going to vote for Obama,
and,
and I think that,
I think it's unfair to say,
and you know,
there's a lot of anti-fat workplace discrimination,
people who are big pay a real economic price.
It has nothing to do with,
I think with their capabilities of their,
you know,
ability to,
to do a job.
Most of us do jobs that require us to sit on our asses and type,
uh,
you know,
we live in an information or a flipping economy and that's it.
And there's nothing about being a even very large that prevents them from doing
that.
And I think it's,
and there's a lot of anti,
you know,
there's a lot of workplace discrimination against big people.
And I think that your attitude towards not wanting to vote for somebody,
for presidents because they're big,
is of that anti-fat prejudice,
that fat acceptance people have total legit complaint about it.
Well,
that's not really necessarily true because when you look at the statistics as
far as people that call in sick,
people that have sick days,
people that show up hours work fat people notoriously Colin's sec more injured,
more have more issues because their body is unhealthy.
I don't want to see those studies.
I don't know
Google them right now.
Again,
I guarantee you there's,
I've read many studies on obesity and workplace.
Okay,
we'll get her and work.
What would you look up workplace?
What?
Obesity.
Workplace discrimination.
Now that's obesity and I can't believe I'm having to like do the,
uh,
the fat acceptance side of this argument because a lot of the fat acceptance
people hate me because I argued that there's a relationship between consumption
movement.
Nobody wants to be judged.
I mean,
that's what it is.
Is Obesity affecting your company's bottom line obesity in the workplace?
Yeah.
All around the world.
Companies are constantly facing many different struggles and hardships that are
triggered by the economy and everyday problems.
Ah,
look,
we could,
we could have this conversation,
but I think it probably would get in the way of an actual podcast.
And anybody wants,
let's talk about sex or something like,
yeah,
well the problem is we would be,
would it be googling things and we wouldn't do a great thorough job of,
of covering it.
And you know,
I w w also we're running into this situation here where in being honest,
you worry about hurting people's feelings and you worry about backlash.
And I know you've faced a bunch of backlash about that.
You faced a bunch of backlash from transgender,
transgender people.
You faced a bunch of backlash from,
so you have to kind of hedge your your points because you worry about this
backlash.
So you have to,
but the reality of being overweight is if you had a friend and they were
overweight and they were willing to listen to you,
you would say you would be healthier and happier if you lost the weight.
Is Fat acceptance that you just ignore that?
I mean,
what does fat acceptance,
you pretend that they're fine.
You pretend that their health,
I can't because it's not health.
I can't do the fat acceptance side of the argument.
You should have somebody from the FAA movement on to talk about it.
But if I had,
if I had a friend who was a big,
you know,
I wouldn't shame them and I wouldn't guilt them.
But if they ask me for advice,
I would definitely say,
you know,
whatever size you're going to be,
the more exercise you get,
the more you move and the more the decent food you eat,
just the better year if you feel in your skin and your body,
whatever your sizes.
I don't question that.
Everybody needs to be.
Every guy needs to be an Adonis and every woman needs to be a size zero.
But I do think that if you move more purely sexually,
you know,
if you move more,
you're gonna have more stamina,
you have more oxygen in your bloodstream and just you feel better in your own
skin.
And that's true for me.
If I don't get exercise,
I get depressed,
depression,
cognitive function.
There's one mother or when she was,
you know,
not too many years older than I am now,
started taking antidepressants and I haven't had to start and I don't think I'm
going to have to start because I'm like my mother.
I actually get exercise and that is my antidepressant and it does work for
people,
but not everybody has the time or the space or the inclination.
I think people should do what makes them happy.
If you want to smoke,
smoke,
if you want to smoke pot,
smoke pot.
If you want to use coke,
I think you're crazy.
But go ahead.
If you,
if you find pleasure in,
in food,
if you are a Gourmand,
if you,
if you are,
what does that someone who lives to eat and finds exquisite pleasure and in
dining and,
and you want,
and this is,
this is what you want to uh,
build your life around because,
because this is what gives you pleasure and that's what we're all here on this
planet doing.
Like finding those things that give us pleasure pursuing happiness.
Um,
great.
Do it.
The only objection I ever make is when,
then I have to pretend that the sky is green and the grass is blue and there
isn't a relationship between calories in movement and size.
So we're in agreement except I would vote for somebody who was cause I think
that's irrelevant when it comes to these irrelevant.
If that person got into the office and they were unhealthy and depressed because
they're obese,
what do you think that would have a thought of?
Affection.
Unhealthy and depressed doesn't correlate only with obesity.
You would have to know all sorts of other things about,
so you're going back to early.
You'd have to know how stressed out their mother was when they were carrying the
baby in Utero to know if they are hair trigger.
Do you want somebody with a hair trigger?
You were with the nuclear correlating those two things.
You were just a correlating obesity and depression.
You were just core a core correlating,
no correlate a city movement and depression,
exercise and depression.
One of the fringe benefits of exercise,
you'll probably be less obese or you lose weight,
but I think it's the endorphins and the movement and the oxygen pumping through
your system.
Not Everybody who exercises is some people are exercise and are,
are,
are very fit.
Our bigger people I have,
I have,
I have an uncle,
I have an uncle who bikes 20 miles a day back and forth to work.
If he's a fat guy,
what does he,
some people are coded to be big.
There were people house,
you can give them a lap band and all of a sudden they shrink down there.
Have smaller portions.
The lap,
I can't believe,
I can't believe I'm here trying to take this position.
It's really cute.
It's cute to watch.
I could see the blowback that you've experienced.
I'll throw your life and God speaking your opinion that don't getting mad at
you.
Trying to have a more nuanced position that I did when people were mad at me.
I'm not conceding ground on calories in movement size being related,
but,
and there is an obesity epidemic.
I do think it's tied,
uh,
largely to,
um,
societal sitters,
corn syrup,
Sedentary Lifestyles,
uh,
laziness,
um,
that can be learned and can be unlearned.
But also there are some people who are their bodies naturally
set to a larger weight.
There are a lot of people who claim that they are,
those people who are not,
they're just eating poorly.
They're just Chris Christie.
Um,
but there are people who retain and this is,
you know,
this is another place are getting in trouble because I want to say,
my husband has a metabolism like,
uh,
like a hive of wasps.
He just burns everything.
I don't know why I was,
would make sense with that hummingbird banding.
Yeah.
He just,
he can,
he can sit down and eat four pints of ice cream and not gain any weight.
I can't.
So I don't,
and when you talk to some people in the fat acceptance movement,
they talk about,
you know,
consumption as if it should be fair as opposed to something you have to be self
aware about.
And like,
I don't want to be big,
so I watch my husband have dessert half the time.
I don't have it myself.
Did nothing's fair when it comes to biology.
Why is it fair that some people have giant noses?
Why is it fair that some people are born?
Yeah,
well there's no fair at any of it.
Some people are born deaf,
there's nothing fair.
You know,
if you are born with a slow metabolism,
that as a reality of the hand that you've been dealt,
you know?
And if you choose to say,
you know what,
I like food more than I like being healthy or a like food more than I like being
thin.
That's fine.
I mean that's your choice.
I'm not,
not saying that you shouldn't be able to make that choice,
but I am saying that if you look at someone that's running for an office or
wants to be a leader,
want to be an example and you have this glaring flaw is glaring flaw that you
kinda gluttonous with the way
that you can take into account.
Um,
but I think,
I honestly think it's irrelevant.
It's not irrelevant.
It's a factor.
It might not be the only factor,
but it's certainly a factor if you,
if a guy just can't wait to end is meaning so he could stuff pinders phase.
What about the people who say that Clinton,
uh,
you know,
because he fucked Monica Lewinsky,
a politician who cheated on his wife can't be trusted not to cheat the country.
That's a silly argument,
right?
So it's a silly argument to say somebody who's undisciplined around food won't
be disciplined enough to be a decent governor who oversees a decent
administration that an ex decent policies that benefit.
But no one's saying that he wouldn't be,
we're saying is this,
you have to judge him based on the whole,
if you judge someone based on the whole,
is that an example that you would want as a leader,
a person who can't get their shit together as far as their body?
I don't,
I don't.
There are people who can't keep their dicks in their pants and I think that's
irrelevant to whether they're going to be a good president.
FDR was a pretty good president and the evidence is clear that he was not just
the sleeping with Eleanor.
If he ever did after awhile,
uh,
and good president JFK was fucking everything and people believe he was a pretty
good president.
Sidestep nuclear annihilation for which we should all be grateful.
Uh,
I think it's irrelevant.
And if that sort of,
uh,
appetite around sex doesn't tell us that someone isn't qualified to be a decent
politician and a good leader,
that kind of appetite around food doesn't tell us anything about whether they're
going to be a good leader or not either,
but isn't a person who is running for president?
Like it wasn't one of the issues that a lot of people have with Obama smoking
and that it sets a bad example.
If the president of United States can't quit smoking like Jesus Christ,
I hate that moral example.
What exam setting?
An example.
That's why Anthony Wiener had to be out of uh,
Congress.
Oh,
think of the children of a liar.
That's the,
there's a lot going on there,
but it's not even just thinking that she'll,
that example is white Ginsburg isn't on the Supreme Court.
Yeah,
but we've talking about something irrelevant like marijuana.
We were talking about something that gives you cancer,
like cigarettes.
This is this.
It's a,
it's a health issue.
If kids see marijuana has kids packs marijuana.
Like what?
Name one.
It makes me slow and stupid.
Please.
That's ridiculous.
If you're slow slowing stupid,
you're slow and stupid because you smoked too much pot and it'll go away.
You are not a healthy knock in your brain around a little bit.
No,
you don't smoke pot.
You're not,
you're not.
There's no,
there's no studies,
no studies whatsoever.
They've shown any cognitive negative side effects of marijuana that are real
during teenage years.
Well,
during formative years,
you shouldn't drink alcohol.
You shouldn't fucking hold your breath.
You should eat whip it.
The argument against Ginsburg to the Supreme Court because he smoked a joint was
he was setting a bad example for those kids.
But it's a bad,
there are demonstrable,
uh,
harms to smoking,
but it's not true because there's no,
nothing has ever been shown.
And all these,
look,
there's a big article that just came out recently.
The DEA spent four decades suppressing information about the positive benefits
of marijuana.
All of the positive effects of marijuana,
far it's shrinking tumors as far as actually improving people that have had
traumatic brain injuries.
There's a lot of pump.
But for pot,
I smoked pot.
But you're,
so you're why you using Ginsburg as an example?
I'm not using Ginsburg and example.
I'm saying that you just said that weight around politicians talking about,
we're talking about cigarettes.
That's a bad example for the kids,
right?
Well,
pot use,
that was the argument against Ginsburg member,
but it's based on ignorance.
It's not based on ignorance.
When you talking about cigarettes,
cigarettes actually do no cigarettes kill 500,000 people every year,
right?
No,
marijuana is cigarettes are the much greater evil.
I'm a pothead.
I see.
Let's just not evil being there on his evils hammers.
Are you not saying because people kill with him.
Not saying marijuana is evil.
There are studies and and sound science that shows that marijuana,
the developing adolescent brain,
we could look it up right now.
Okay.
The developing adolescent brain is a different about whether it's a good
example.
Who are we talking about when we say something?
It's a bad example.
We're talking about the kitties.
That was the argument used to keep Ginsburg off the supreme court that his pot
use was going to send the wrong message to kids.
That's what you're just talking about with cigarettes and the president.
Here's the problem with anybody saying that marijuana gives a bad is bad for the
formative years of children.
You're not testing kids and saying,
okay,
we're going to take a bunch of kids that are healthy and normal and we're going
to have a study group.
We're going to give the marijuana and we're going to have people that are equal
in their cognitive abilities.
Do I want to give them no,
no,
no marijuana.
We don't have that.
So we don't have is a bunch of people that have issues and you'd that have
issues and he says,
oh well they do marijuana.
Well,
Gee,
is marijuana the cause of the issues?
Are there a bunch of factors?
Are they depressed?
Do they have mental illness issues?
Is something running in their family?
Holier codes?
I have a 17 six and four do you want it to 17 year olds smoking pot right now?
I don't have a problem with it.
Yeah,
I don't think it's an issue.
I think alcohol is a bit much bigger issue.
I agree.
I wrote that in a book that I don't think it's 15 I'd rather he was smoking pot
than drinking.
I don't think kids should,
a drug that takes the edge off as opposed to puts the edge on alcohol makes kids
boys particularly aggressive.
And we know this from the same sorts of bullshit studies that you would slam for
pot.
No,
no,
we don't do,
we don't do controlled studies,
medical studies on humans,
so we don't have evidence,
uh,
the same sort of evidence that we have for other things that we can do
controlled studies on a control group,
cell studies.
But there is a confluence of evidence that pot is for the developing adolescent
brain,
not the greatest idea.
And maybe with art children's brains,
we should err on the side of caution and encourage them to maybe wait for pot
for after their brains are fully formed.
Hypothalamus,
it interferes with judgment around risk taking according to the studies that I
have read.
Yeah.
The studies that,
again,
we talked about this,
the,
the real issue is these children already have issues.
They're issues.
The correlation between marijuana may or may not be the reason why they got into
this situation,
that it has the same cultural effects that marijuana has.
Has that impact can't,
it can be just sort of like,
we can just dismiss it as not being impactful.
We use marijuana.
We,
we use marijuana because it's impact.
Yes.
But do you know how many kids smoked pot in high school and our fucking fine
guys.
Gigantic.
I know,
I tell myself that every day.
Uh,
numbers checked,
fingers crossed.
I really don't think that that's nearly the issue.
I was 34,
but I know most other people don't.
Including,
you know,
I have friends who are,
who are,
whose careers I will not mention lest I identify them.
Uh,
who haven't spoken pot since they were 12.
I don't think that being a teenage pot smoker means you're going to be a wasted
loser as an adult.
So what are you saying?
I am saying it's tough on the brain.
I don't know if it is.
I really don't.
I mean I think anything we you abuse talked about talking about versus abuse.
You talk about skewed samples.
I think,
you know,
when I think about my own son and I think about,
whether what he might be doing or what he is doing,
um,
I always reassure myself with,
you know,
I know this person was smoking pot all through high school and middle school and
this person and that person,
everybody I know so many of them are,
you know,
we're using pot in high school,
Middle School,
and they're fine.
And then everyone.
So I think,
yeah,
but the guys who are using pot in middle school and high school aren't fine.
I wouldn't know them as a natal,
they wouldn't be part of my sphere as an adult.
So I don't have a representative sample of the impact of pot on the adolescent
brain because the people I know who are successful,
who smoked pot,
they were a middle school students and high school students are fine because the
people who smoked pot who derailed their lives or it did have some negative
impact,
they're not anybody I would ever meet.
Right.
I don't know what you're saying.
The people that derailed their life,
you wouldn't meet them.
They wouldn't,
you know,
I the,
I am a successful person.
I hang out with like responsible,
sane,
successful people who have their shit together.
Right?
I don't hang out with people who don't have their shit together so that I
reassure myself about adolescent drug use as I parent and adolescent because
everybody I know who's an adult who is an adolescent drug user is fine,
only goes so far because everybody,
I don't know who was an adolescent drug use here isn't fine.
I wouldn't know those people.
So I don't have a fully representative sample.
My study of like everybody I know is fine isn't any more scientifically sound
than the studies of pot use and its impact on adolescents that you're
condemning?
Well,
I think you can be really clear that anytime you're altering consciousness,
you,
you run risks and you have rewards,
there's positive benefits,
there's negatives and it can be argued that there are positive benefits to
altering your consciousness when you were young because it forces you to step
outside of the predetermined pattern of behavior that's been prescribed to you
by society and culture.
And it gives you a chance to,
as a young person,
look at this world that you live in and go,
you know what?
I don't want to be my fucking parents.
I don't know how to be that teacher.
That's an asshole.
I don't want to be the principal.
I,
I want to figure out what it is about what they're telling me that's true and
what it is about this life that we live that is just operating on momentum.
And that is something that marijuana provides young people and I don't think
it's something they should abuse.
And I don't think it's something that should be,
anybody should smoke on a regular basis,
on a daily basis all day.
I think that clouding your reality consistently and constantly,
whether it's with mushrooms or marijuana,
it becomes a very,
very slippery thing.
And I think it's not good for consciousness.
I think consciousness can be enhanced by adding psychedelics to it,
whether it's psychotropic plants,
medicines,
meditation,
Yoga,
all those different things have psychedelic effects.
And one of the things about psychedelic effects is the reset option.
The option to go there,
do something,
have this ability to step outside of the pattern that you find yourself right
now that hasn't happened.
One cigarettes and that does cigarettes just,
and that's why this argument is disingenuous.
The cigarette thing about being a bad example,
there's zero fucking benefits.
The sucking on a thing that kills half a million people a year.
Costs money,
smells like shit.
When you see a guy like the president who smoked cigarettes and you say,
well that guy is up setting a bad example.
I think that's pretty fucking valid.
And if the president had smoked marijuana sometime in his life,
like Ginsburg,
and in a way,
guess he's admitted that he talks about it,
I don't think it's as big a deal.
You know what I think is the worst example in the president's cases that he
smoked pot,
didn't get caught,
didn't get caught up in the criminal justice system as a young African American
male and treats marijuana decriminalization once he becomes president.
And some big joke,
I don't.
Yeah.
When it could have destroyed his life.
The punitive racist anti drug policies that we have in this country could have
destroyed his life.
And as soon as he,
you know,
he gets elected president as having been an out pot smoker and acts like any
suggestion about marijuana decriminalization or reform is beneath contempt and
shouldn't be considered.
And he says because of the kids,
that hypocrisy of the president's around pot is so much more offensive to me
than the president's idiocy around getting addicted to cigarettes.
I agree.
And I think it speaks to the
common thoughts of the people.
I mean if you looked at,
if you wanted to pull people and tried to appease the people,
you would say something like that.
Like the president said that it's speaking to the children,
worrying about the children.
That's a good thing to do.
If you want to be a politician,
if you want to not speak your mind and not be honest and support the facts,
but instead go with the flow and that's what the flow of this country is.
This,
the country is still worried about the flow,
but prop up a system that could have destroyed you.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Without a doubt.
No argument there.
I mean,
look,
the drug policies that we have,
and they're not just racist,
they're ridiculous.
I mean,
we don't have a society that avoids drugs.
We don't have a drug free society by any stretch of the imagination.
We have a society where you could drive down this fucking street in every single
restaurant served drugs,
every single one.
Go to cvs.
You could drink yourself to death.
You just walk right in to cvs,
buy a gallon of Jack Daniel's,
drink it all in one shot.
You're a fucking dead man.
You could go to that pill counter.
And if you have the right doctor,
he can prescribe you the right medication.
You fucking suck the whole bottle down with a shot of whiskey and your argument
done.
So this idea of a drug free societies,
preposterous.
I had Dr. Carl Hart on who's a,
an expert in addiction.
And one of the things that he said that's so important is not only will we never
have a drug free society,
you don't want a drug free society,
you don't want it.
And it's just the idea of people drugs.
Well it's not just that,
it's the idea of sanction drugs as opposed to,
you know,
an unsanctioned drugs like who,
what is the benefit of these sanction drugs?
And if you look at it,
it's clear there's an economic motive to have some drug sanctioned in some not.
If that wasn't the case,
well God damn it.
Wouldn't the fucking president be complaining about cigarettes?
Wouldn't politicians to be saying we're going to outlaw cigarettes cause you're
dealing with a drug that kills a massive amount of people in this country.
It prematurely half a million people a year just in this country.
Millions worldwide wouldn't,
uh,
president step up.
Wouldn't someone who's running for office,
someone who's in a position of leadership say something against that.
The reason why they don't is economics.
It's really simple.
The reason why nicotine is not sanction drug is purely because of x
economics and the selective selectively learned lessons of prohibition.
We can't ban cigarettes.
We,
we did,
we banned alcohol because it was bad for people led to family breakups and
violence and Serosa deliberate,
organized many,
many millions of dots and we,
you know,
had alcohol prohibition and it fueled organized crime and people drank anyway.
So prohibition doesn't work.
So one's gonna Argue for the prohibition
of cigarettes wouldn't work for the exact same reasons.
And then you ask those same people about drug prohibition and they go,
what,
don't don't,
it doesn't compute.
Right.
So the,
you know,
the same argument that you would make for legalizing pot and probably other
drugs,
uh,
prevents you from banning cigarettes.
I think this goes back to what we were talking about earlier,
that we live in a world where information is readily accessible and we live in
that world very briefly.
This has only been around for a couple of decades.
1994 ish.
When the Internet came along really probably in the two thousands when people
started really accessing and on a regular basis and using search search engines
and finding answers to questions.
All these people that are basing all of these ideas that they have there,
they're based on the momentum of an ignorant past.
I mean,
that's essentially what we're,
we're,
we're dealing with.
So I think that what we're dealing with right now with this scramble to try to
figure out what should be legal and what shouldn't be legal and why is this
legal and this is sanctioned and we got to worry about the children.
It's just this adolescent stage that we're in.
We're,
we're learning how to process information and we're learning how to base our
decisions and base our ideas and our ideologies on reality as opposed to these
stupid ideas that we have about reefer madness or you know,
the,
or the ideas that they had about what,
what Booz could do to IU.
Yeah.
Boos can fuck you up.
It doesn't mean it should be legal.
I like it.
I like booze.
It should be legal.
I like that.
I could go to a bar and get a shot.
I like it.
I think you're ban cigarettes.
If you could do whatever the fuck you want.
I don't mind cigars,
cigarettes.
I think you should be able to get heroin.
I think he should be able to do whatever the fuck you want.
Kids can still get heroin.
It's not as easy,
but they can still get heroin.
I think that Oxycontin's are a huge fucking problem.
A friend of mine,
a different one who,
uh,
has a,
um,
high school kids,
his kid,
their friends got in trouble from fucking snorting oxycontin's and it's a huge
problem.
It's a huge problem with the kids' schools because they steal it from their
parents.
Their parents had a back injury.
That fucking goes on forever because pharmaceutical companies don't mind if they
continue to keep selling you these fucking oxycontin's.
He steals it from his mother cause she's whacked out of her fucking mind on
heroin.
Take,
take it to school,
smash it up and snort it.
And it's an issue.
And it's an issue with a lot of high school kids today.
You know,
I think we have a real problem with people wanting to do things to escape
reality.
We have a real problem and one of the real problems that we have is we don't
represent reality clearly to children.
We don't represent what a drug really is.
We don't.
Five minutes ago you were saying it's good for kids to experiment drugs a little
bit to test reality against an alternative reality.
We're talking about very differently about heroin is a very different subject.
We're talking about something that can kill you,
something that's physically addictive and marijuana,
which is fairly innocuous when you look at all the chuggers or sanction illegal,
but so mushrooms,
totally legal,
hundred percent legal beneficial.
Not only that I think will change the world.
We wish to be able to get heroin if we want it,
and I think it,
I don't think you should be able to tell me that I can't do heroin and I think
that's what happens when you just have
laws.
That's what happens with this.
The same thing.
I don't think you should be able to tell me what I should or shouldn't be able
to do if the whole world was just Dan savage and Joe Rogan.
Okay,
I'm on your side.
If you have heroin was legal.
Like Ron Paul said in one of the Republican debates.
Oh,
last time that I was like,
I've written that,
you know,
he said that her one should be legal in the republican crowd booed.
And he looked at them and said,
if it was legal,
would you do it?
That's a good question.
I live in Seattle.
The streets are paved with heroin.
You can get heroin and we're having a spike.
Again,
what happens in Seattle is,
you know,
whole bunch of people die and then everybody stops using heroin and then
everybody forgets and then everybody has to like lose some friends again.
Um,
there's a stupid learning curve with heroin and we're going through it again.
But if you know,
I'm pretty pro drugs,
I've used lots of different kinds of drugs and I believe in moderation in all
things,
including moderation and the best advice you can get if you find a recreational
drug that really works for you is to use that very rarely.
Cause at that impact it has the first time.
If you use it constantly,
you'll never have that impact ever again.
So if mushrooms,
if you really liked that mushroom trip,
wait a few years and then do it again,
do it Tuesday.
It's very different than heroin,
the comparison.
But the idea was that heroin,
heroin was legal.
I wouldn't be coming to comparison to mushrooms.
I'm not,
you just did.
I'm,
no,
I'm talking about moderation in all things.
No,
no,
no.
But my heroin is toxic.
Mushrooms or psychedelics and they're not toxic at all.
The LD 50 rate for mushrooms is through the,
I was just digressing off of,
uh,
believing that drugs should be legal in the heroin thing that we're learning now
with heroin.
But the thing is of heroin was legal.
If I could walk to a pharmacy and buy it,
I wouldn't cause I don't want to do it.
Good point.
But if like Ron Paul,
I think it would change the consciousness period.
I think human beings would develop a completely different sense of reality
itself.
Completely different south of our perspective in the universe.
I've used mushrooms and I didn't mind expanding.
He probably took a small dose.
How much do I need to take?
Five grams usually in darkness.
If you can get an isolation tank go that way.
Oh yeah.
Don't be a pussy.
If you're talking about mushrooms and you haven't gone the big route,
I have a finger on,
you know,
you've dipped your toes in the water.
You haven't jumped into the ocean.
Can I tell you what my mushrooms story,
it's pretty funny with some friends we went camping,
we were doing mushrooms and uh,
we're all standing in this lake in Idaho with some like redneck families camping
all around us and we're like two gay guys and two straight go straight couple
and were just tripping out of our minds,
our mushrooms.
There were standing.
It's like in these fish are nibbling or the hairs on her legs and we're all like
whoa.
And then suddenly there's a boat going back and forth in front of us that has
dare the drug resistance education logo.
That's like the police boat that's going back and forth in front of us.
And then a prop airplane comes right at us.
We're like standing there and this airplane is like,
we see it in the sky,
it's getting lower and lower.
It's pointed right at us.
It comes over right at us at the boat.
And we were all like,
we see are you seeing an airplane to each other?
And
then the airplane went right over our heads and we all shit ourselves.
We were terrified.
We look,
how would the fucking disappeared like right behind us on this little rise.
And we're like,
what the fuck?
And we ran up there thinking it was going to be a plane crash and there is a
runway.
See,
cause we come down to the beach sideways and along the sand and there was an
airport right there.
But there was this moment where like we're tripping,
the fish are eating us,
the dare boats going like this,
which is making us paranoid and now here comes the plane for our heads and have
it done.
Mushroom said so maybe that's why.
Yeah,
that's probably a bad place to do mushrooms set and setting is one of the most
important thing that has any sort of,
well where you were on a boat with a fucking dare boat going by in a plane
flying and you rent a runway.
We had no idea we were standing at the foot of a runner.
Silence is usually the best option,
you know,
silence and darkness is with Terence Mckenna prescribed silent darkness is the
best way to do any sort of psychedelic because then you were alone with the
psychedelic and not any sort of external factors that you would have to take
into consideration when you experienced the trip.
But I'll file that away.
Yeah,
I mean do what you want,
but I think if you want to do mushrooms,
it should be God damn legal.
And I think if it was legal,
we changed the world.
I think we had sanctioned centers where people could go and have what we
consider a modern day Sharman.
Someone who understood the reactions to these drugs had pure drugs.
And again,
the problem is the word drug cause drugs is giant blanket that we throw over
aspirin and caffeine and alcohol and psychedelics.
I mean it's preposterous that all these things with radically different results,
radically different effects on the human body are all under the same blanket.
I mean it's crazy.
I mean command than if all food in me just food was just a blank term for food
and all food had incredible meet.
Some of them were anabolic and they made,
made you grow giant muscles and other ones were toxic and they fucked you up.
And if food was so,
it was differentiated by that and one blanket term,
it would be really weird,
you know?
But no,
we have vegetables and we have meets and we have fish and we have what?
GTE?
I had fruit,
I had food.
You don't say I had food.
Which do?
It took drugs.
What kind of drugs did you take?
I took heroin.
Oh,
took aspirin.
I took aspirin.
What does it,
is that a drug,
you know?
You know what I mean?
It's like I took caffeine.
Oh,
that's not a drug.
You just drank coffee,
but it says drug.
Oh,
I had a cigarette.
That's not a drug.
Yes it is.
Yeah.
You to drug distribution device.
It's you burn,
it gets in your bloodstream very quickly that way.
Yeah.
It's a drug like what?
That's a drug to,
yes,
that's a drug.
I don't do drugs but I like to drink.
You're fucking doing drugs.
God dammit.
We have a real problem with our definitions.
We have a real problem with that one blanket term and that's why we have this
war against drugs.
It's fucking ridiculous.
No,
it's fucking not ending is it is a restart up.
If some other fucking dumped on gets an office like Chris Christie,
that dummy who think marijuana should be legal on my watch cheeseburgers,
sucking asshole once to keep marijuana out of his state.
There's facts on the ground and there's a exit campy unscrambled and I think
what's happening in Washington state and Colorado around patch was undone cash
wise.
Yeah.
I think that's what it is.
I think it's the generation of income,
but I think that's what's changing the whole game because money influences
politics more than anything.
And corporations have been able to get the sort of the,
the hold on that they've had a monopoly on influence through money.
But I think that now what you're seeing with Colorado first year,
first of all,
39% is what their tax marijuana on and Colorado recreationally,
medically,
it's far lower,
but 39% recreationally.
And people are like,
okay,
39 is fine.
No one's complaining it off.
So because of that,
you're getting hundreds of millions of dollars of potential revenue.
The first year is going to be over a hundred million dollars.
That's a lot of fucking money.
And when that kind of money happens,
then Republicans start thinking about owning it,
owning warehouses filled with marijuana,
grow hops.
And when that happens,
yeah,
and,
and hopefully they'll smoke a little and fucking relax and feel a little
paranoid.
That's a good part.
Feeling Humble Republicans do not have a problem with feeling paranoid.
Well,
they should feel paranoid about their actions and their thoughts and the lack of
compassion that they showed of various aspects of our society.
I think that's one of the things that marijuana does,
the vulnerability that people like to call it,
paranoia,
in my opinion,
it's a,
it's a heightening of awareness and it's taking off your blinders and making you
recognize it.
You should be a little paranoid.
You should be a little,
a little more humble.
Nobody likes cocky people.
Nobody likes people that aren't afraid of anything fucking fearless and think
that they're the shit that's like one of the worst aspects of,
of human beings.
Right?
Well,
that's one of the one things that marijuana chips away at.
It slammed that thing right down into the gutter and makes you realize,
look,
you fucking not here for very long,
man.
You're not here for very long and consider the whole picture considered the big
thing.
That's what psychedelics do.
They allow you to consider things in a way other than this pattern is groove
that you've sort of cut in by driving the same way to work every day and dealing
with the same church and dealing with the same people in your office and the
same fucking NRA newsletters you get everyday.
You're carving a path of of cognitive dissonance and you don't realize it until
you do something that makes you get out of that path.
How do we get some mushrooms to Sarah Palin?
Yeah,
you go,
Sarah Pailin needs a lot.
She needs a lot,
but she can in isolation.
She also,
we need an isolation tank for her.
We all,
everyone needs an isolation tech.
I think literally everyone needs one.
I think it's one of the most positive things you could ever have in your life.
The the chance to be alone with your thoughts.
It's a very rare thing.
Even when you meditate,
you feel the ground underneath your butt.
You feel your hands sitting on your knees.
You know,
you feel your fingertips touching each other.
You feel,
you hear things,
you're,
you're in a room.
You can open your eyes,
you see the room.
You know,
even even that it's,
it's good to meditate.
It's great.
It's way better to meditate in an isolation tank.
A woman just float,
right?
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
Sensory deprivation tanks were invented by a guy named John Lilly who was a
pioneer,
an interspecies communication is he used to take acid and is it set up a dolphin
tank next to his isolation tank and you try to communicate with the dolphins.
They're doing acid in a sensory deprivation tank.
And it was a fascinating,
fascinating guy,
but he was trying to figure out a way to remove the influence of the external
reactions that the body has to stimuli,
to touching things and hearing things.
And he was the first one that he invented.
He had a,
uh,
like a mask,
a good giant like scuba diver,
old school,
Jules Verne type bubble head.
And it was strapped with all these harnesses and he would just float with this
air bubble that attached to his head.
And that was his first tank with warm water.
The water has to be essentially the same temperature as the surface of your skin
so you don't feel the water anymore,
but you still feel the straps and the helmet.
And he kind of ignored that and we'd go into this state and then he figured out
that you could just put really,
really salty water.
So the tank has 800 to a thousand pounds of salt in an Epsom salts,
which is actually a very good way of absorbing magnesium because it's absorbed
through the skin and you lie down on this tank,
the temperature's the same temperature as the surface of your skin.
Close the door at total silence,
total darkness,
half your body's underwater.
And in the absence of sensory input,
any sensory input your brain has resources that are beyond what you ever achieve
in everyday life.
Because if we're having this conversation,
there's a jackhammer going off next door.
It would be very distracting.
We would want to go in the other room,
but we didn't hear the Jackhammer and that would be a relief.
Well,
life is a fucking jackhammer.
Everything you do is,
is,
is input.
It's all changed the water.
I wouldn't want to use the water if somebody else,
well it depends.
Yeah,
that's,
that's one thing.
Um,
it depends on where you go.
They always change the water.
First of all,
they changed the water and there's massive filtration systems that are involved.
Like the,
the place that I go to a that I got my tank from is a place called the float lab
and this guy crash will be on the podcast.
We're working on getting them on here.
He has developed this intense,
uh,
filtration system that also involves ozone ozone,
which kills anything that might be alive inside of the water.
The water itself being so hyper salinated that kills everything as well.
And it goes through two massive filters,
which are intensely small amount of particles or you know,
they're all filtered out of this system.
And then you change the water,
you know,
regularly as well.
If it's a commercial thing,
mine my keep my water in there for six,
seven months at a time,
maybe a year at a time.
That's fine.
But that's the least of your problems.
You know,
there's very few things are going to survive in that water.
I mean you could have some Weirdo appeasing and I guess take a shower
afterwards,
don't worry.
But the,
the,
the benefits of an isolation being totally do it.
They have place in Seattle.
The guys in Seattle messages me all the time.
They started it after they heard about it on the podcast.
Hello?
Yeah,
they started a tank center.
Um,
I know there's at least two in Seattle.
There's one that just opened up an Austin.
This guy is a bad motherfucker was creating them out of a,
he's using like a boat halls,
like the same companies that manufactured bolt holes and he's having them build
these tanks to his specifications so that there's no lining.
You don't have to have a liner at the bottom of them because some of the old
ones that these to make kind of flimsy and the liner was like a water bed liner
and sometimes it would break and it would leak and it would be a huge pain in
the ass.
You have to drain it and then put another new liner in.
Sometimes the heaters or burnout and it would cook through the liner.
But crash uses this liner that's like,
I'm a Koi pond liner.
This is really thick rubber and it's not,
nothing's going to break that thing.
It's,
it's,
it's excellent and I think it's a huge resource and if no one's had one,
you're really doing yourself a disservice.
It's an amazing thing and it's a chance to have a psychedelic experience with no
drugs.
Your mind in the absence of any sensory input becomes very sexy,
delicate.
You,
you would recommend also doing mushrooms and getting in the tank if you really
ready to go deep.
That's the way to do it.
Lily.
Lily used to do it with ketamine.
He sees you in intramuscular shots of ketamine and going to that,
which I don't recommend is ketamine has some pretty severe addictive properties
to it.
And Yeah,
horse tranquilizer,
cat it.
Cat Tranquilizer.
Yeah.
No,
I think it's cat.
Um,
whatever the fuck a tranquilizer that we use on animals,
veterinary tranquilizer,
but uh,
has some intense psychedelic properties to it.
Apparently.
I'm going to have to go.
You gotta go.
I gotta get to the end of the earth by three o'clock.
Shit,
we had so much other things to talk about.
Do you want to rattle off by them?
No,
no,
we don't have to.
Uh,
look,
I just think,
um,
I wanted to talk about the transgender thing to find out why people were angry
at you.
What,
where transgender people angry.
Uh,
there's,
um,
a segment of the Trans community that believes that you shouldn't be allowed to
use the word tranny.
That trainee is a hate term.
Um,
I have in my column savage love,
and on my podcast I have a podcast,
the savage Lovecast,
uh,
but in the column when I started in [inaudible] 91,
um,
as part of Queer nation,
and there was this movement to reclaim hate words.
And so I used Queer Faggot,
dyke,
sissy,
tranny,
and breeder,
which is our Hayward for straight people.
Um,
you can use that by the way.
We don't mind [inaudible] have a problem with that.
Let's have a hate term and more of an acknowledgement of your utility because we
do reproduce ourselves out of your bodies for the most part.
Um,
and you know,
about four years ago,
kind of a top secret memo went out that trainee was no longer worried that
people could use and top secret.
Well in a way like tranny,
which had always sort of been okay to use became not okay,
it became the t word.
Now it's the t slur.
Uh,
and that's a little like weird and dishonest about it is all usages of it prior
to the movement to get people to stop using it are considered hate speech.
Um,
I've stopped using it.
I only use it when I'm asked about why this word is problematic or why I don't
use it anymore.
Um,
but there's certain chunk of the Trans Community that can't,
uh,
can't accept a change and wants to continue to scream and yell about prior
usages that they objected to when I don't use it anymore.
Yeah.
People super sensitive about words.
I think intent is the most important thing.
Faggot.
Uh,
when I started savage love,
I'm gay and it's an advice column for straight people,
mostly about straight sex and the salutation.
Like,
dear Abby,
every letter B in another column with dear Abby.
Um,
every letter in my column again with Hey Faggot,
that's what you wanted to call savage love.
It's what I wanted to call it to begin with.
And that really proved that intent made a word hateful,
not the string of letters,
because some people would write a faggot.
I love your column,
I love your advice.
Please help me.
I think you're awesome.
And then the next letter would be,
hey,
faggot,
you're a cock sucking sodomite piece of shit.
You should go to hell and burn and die.
Obviously in the first letter faggot,
it was a compliment.
This person was using faggot affectionately.
This person was eating faggot.
The way I use faggot with my husband.
And the second letter,
this is somebody using it.
Hatefully and that just proved that intent made a word hateful,
not the word.
And so now,
you know,
I still use faggot in the column.
I'm not one of those,
uh,
gay rights activists who when David Spade or Jonah Hill or Alec Baldwin uses
Faggot like falls down and screams and yells and calls for their heads.
I've actually defended David spade,
well a million years ago from glad when they were after him.
I think Louis C K does it a hilarious things with faggot.
So I don't think that it's not a hate word anymore if you can't let straight
people use it when the Kate,
when their intent is clearly not hateful.
And so I feel like it shouldn't be a problem for people to use the t word tranny
in a non hateful context.
But so many trans people are so invested right now politically in stopping its
usage at all ever.
And uh,
you know,
in deference to their delicate sensibilities,
I've stopped the delicate sensibilities things.
Totally understandable.
I mean,
I couldn't imagine what it would be like growing up in one gender,
wanting to be another gender and experiencing just a massive amount of hate and
rejection your whole life.
Because of that trans people face is off the charts,
the discrimination,
the suicide rate,
the employment conditions,
the violence and the numbers of people who are trans who are murdered every year
is outrageous.
You know,
when we talk about anti gay bullying,
it's usually tied to gender nonconformity.
Uh,
it's like girls who are masculine and boys who are sissies and a lot of those
kids who are gender nonconforming or also trans kids.
So a lot of that anti queer bullying of Queer youth is anti-trans bullying.
It is really the movement of the moment when it comes to sexual rights and
sexual minorities and gender rights,
gender expression,
minorities.
Um,
and it's,
they have legitimate things I think to be extremely angry about.
But I think some of that anger gets diverted into word policing.
That's not helpful.
Like Bill O'reilly was just on TV last week,
telling the parents of trans kids to do what all the research shows,
drives those kids to suicide.
What does that,
what was he saying?
Reject them.
What to reject them to refuse to acknowledge their identities too.
He was not telling people this is,
he was objecting to this video with these parents who had allowed their kid to
transition and he was saying,
you should never do that.
And was really just giving the,
if you want your,
if you want to drive your trans kid to suicide,
do what bill O'Reilly is telling you to do.
And there wasn't as much screaming and yelling about that as there was about Ru
Paul using female or shemale on Rupaul's drag race.
And that seems a little like disproportionate to me,
the butt.
But you can,
but you know,
ru Paul will listen and logo,
we'll listen and maybe change.
And I think the sense is that there's nothing they could say to a Riley that's
going to stop him from hating and trolling,
uh,
trans people or the parents of trans kids trolling.
So there's no word for what he does as well.
So there's no benefit in going after a Riley,
whereas he could go after logo and they will change.
But when you want to raise the awareness,
when you want to save kids who are trans from the kind of parental bullying and
rejection that leads to suicide,
I think you do need to go after her Riley.
Yeah.
What is,
what was he saying?
He's saying that they should ignore kids that are saying that they're
transgender.
They should tell their kid.
They should insist that this little kid who was grow out of it,
who is identified as female at birth,
which is how you have to say it now,
um,
was not actually a male and they should,
you know,
refuse to let the kid transition or live as the gender that the kid knows itself
to be refuse.
Yeah.
Like,
how do you refuse to,
well you did,
this happens all the time to turn those kids where there's a kid who,
you know,
uh,
was born a girl,
which,
you know,
you,
some people,
some trans people would say that even that,
a formula that I use now to talk about that kid is itself Trans phobic.
There's a kid who's born a girl who,
who,
who is male.
The,
the brain has a gender.
It's gendered and wants to bring the body into alignment with the brain.
And there are parents who will bully that kid who will refuse to let that kid
express their gender,
their real gender as opposed to the gender they appeared to be at birth,
uh,
because of their genitalia.
Um,
who will,
you know,
not allow the kid to cut her hair,
cut his hair into a masculine haircut,
one,
allow that kid to wear boy clothes when allowed that kid to use,
uh,
the,
the male Pronoun to be He,
uh,
and that sort of rejection and creates the dysphoria,
creates the inner conflict that for a lot of trans gets,
destroys them.
And so,
oh Riley was saying to these people do that that you should just force them.
Yeah.
Wow.
Well it goes back to the whole pink hair thing.
It does.
It does bring people to do anything outside of like some of those who are in the
LGBT movement as I am.
Um,
but who are not ourselves trans look at the like focus on language and pronouns
and who said what when and who stopped and who didn't and think this is a lot of
effort being expended,
lecturing your allies and going after people who are on your side.
Meanwhile,
you know,
O'Reilly's pumping this through Fox News into homes all across the country and
to conservative homes in red states and places where there may actually be trans
kids who are very vulnerable to that kind of parental rejection.
That might be something we want to focus on.
You see how they would think,
well if we could get you to stop doing it,
that would be a step in the right direction.
And then from there we could just stop.
I have stopped.
The word tranny though to me is like he realized here is Hab driver and you're a
Cabbie.
You know,
that's a problem.
Is it negative training?
Is it negative?
That is,
that is a lot of people's argument.
That trainee is this affectionate,
diminutive for transgender also for a transvestite,
right.
And a lot of transgenders for people objected very vociferously to being lumped
in with transvestites are not the same thing.
Um,
but you know,
a lot of people who do drag,
particularly old school drag queens like RuPaul been around for a long time who
self identified as trainees and our sort of have a moment of a time of an era
when a transgender people and drag queens and a lot of people who were drag
kings and scenesters,
we're really part of the same clicks and subcultures.
And so that the use of the word tranny wasn't,
uh,
what's this umbrella term that,
that,
that spoke of unity between transgender people and other people who are gender
nonconforming like a ru Paul,
like a drag queen or Justin Bond.
And so they don't understand this sudden desire,
particularly on the part of a lot of young trans activists to declare this word
that you know,
for Ru Paul's generation meant unity between who he was or who she is and who
his trans brothers and sisters were like.
That was the word that unified them.
And they're saying that this is a word that stigmatized,
and this is a word that cannot be used anymore.
And I think,
uh,
the Ru Paul,
you know,
Rupaul doesn't,
uh,
that doesn't understand.
He rejects it.
He thinks it's misplaced.
And uh,
he still uses the word.
I don't,
well,
except when I talk about it,
I will get grief for this conversation.
You need to use the word to talk about not using the word is a problem.
So you should say the t word sort of like saying the n word.
Like if a white person starts saying nigger in a conversation instead of the n
word,
it becomes an issue.
I said,
he said,
at least I love Louis Ck is,
but that the n word is just what white people say to get away with saying yes
and make you're making someone think of you're making it someone say it to
themselves,
do you say n word?
And they have to say nigger in their own heads.
I got in trouble with the Trans community because there was a woman who used to
be a man who was a man for 30 years and then decided to start MMA fighting and
fighting women.
And I said,
there's some physical advantages to the male frame that I think it's unfair and
it is also,
it's,
you have to divulge the fact that you used to be a man.
There's structural advantages to the male frame,
this mechanical advantages to the male frame,
especially when it comes to fighting.
And I think that that's not fair.
And people were so upset at me and then it's a medical issue and that it's been
proven that,
uh,
a man of trends becomes a transgender as a woman and a woman,
period.
And I'm like,
yeah,
no,
I don't think so.
I mean the frame that the width of the shoulders,
the size of the hands,
these things don't change.
And it takes a long time to change the bone density.
More than a decade of hormone therapy to show significant decreases in bone
density.
And they try to pretend that it's like some sort of an instantaneous thing that
you automatically become a woman.
But this woman who used to be a man looked like a man and a lot of ways,
a very wide,
broad shouldered and hit very hard.
And I think that's a lot of it is the mechanical advantage of the male frame.
Does it mean that a woman can't beat her?
No.
I mean,
or a cis woman as you would say?
No,
absolutely can.
And not only that,
I think she should be able to compete with them,
but I think it's a,
it's a matter of disclosure.
You can't not tell them that.
You can't just pretend you've been a woman your whole life.
I think when it comes to something along that line that's,
that's a big issue.
And that's how the current,
the current wave of sort of trans thought,
which is you know,
evolving and developing rapidly would say that it's hate speech for you to say
that this person wasn't a woman all her life,
well,
there weren't physically a woman.
That's reality that a penis,
they had muscles,
they had testosterone flowing freely through the testicles.
That's,
that's the reality.
The scientific reality of having the y chromosome and that is what a man is.
Whether they gender identified with being a female,
I'm not disputing that whatsoever and even if they looked like a man,
I'd be more than happy to call them and address them and think of them as a
woman.
I have no problem with that.
It just becomes to combat sports when it comes to combat sports.
When you,
there's a reason why men and women are a lot of fight each other.
It's because men have an advantage is a women's division in the men's division
and I don't,
I don't even have a problem with a woman fighting a man if they know,
if everybody knows what's going on.
If Rhonda Rousey decides to fight another hundred 35 pound man,
she's probably gonna beat the fuck out of the average 30 135 pounds.
I know nothing about this sport.
This is the first I've heard that there was a trans person in the sport.
I can't watch this sport,
but you,
but you've commented on it.
You said that a lot of people that watch it may be closeted gay.
Have I commented on?
Yes.
Oh,
this is the,
the,
the mixed martial arts with pumping on the floor while they're trying to kill
each other because you want to call it humping like you're doing too hot guys
end up in there like grabbing each other and rolling around on the Mat.
On the floor and inside the metal.
Yeah,
I have,
I've seen it.
I'm not light.
It's not a sport.
I follow much.
I seen it at my gym that I used to go to where they would have mixed martial
arts.
Is that what it's called?
Yes.
On all these screens.
And then I would go around and turn all the TVS to bravo when I was alone in the
gym at night.
In the morning when you're falling,
that allowed you to change the channel.
I would just stand there on the side of the TV until Kathy Griffith on Bravo.
I mean,
making this too much ago.
But you were saying that you thought that a lot of people that did MMA or
watched on I would probably just joking.
I was just cheesing.
Cause you know,
there's some people who are into Hypo Macho sports at any suggestion that there
could be anything gay about it or that even a gay person could get anything out
of it.
So you were trolling,
I was just trolling you son of a bitch.
Listen man,
we could do this a million
times.
We could have a lot of really fun conversations even though we disagree on
certain things.
A,
I respect your opinion very much.
And I think it's a very interesting point of view and a,
I think that a lot of these subjects,
I mean there's no definitive yes or no.
There's no right or wrong.
They're very nuanced and a really fun conversation
really does and if you're ever in Seattle and you want to come on my podcast and
give some sex advice,
I would love to love to have you.
Yeah,
definitely.
I love Seattle,
man.
I don't have it in the winter,
but I love in the summer it's one of the best places on earth.
It's winter right now.
You know what we call June in Seattle.
Wa January.
Why?
Because it's cold and raining.
Just like Jan.
Really?
Yeah.
It's been shitty.
Cold,
raining all month.
Does that freak people out that live there?
Because the people that I know that live there,
they all brush it off like,
no,
it's not.
It's awesome.
Come move here.
I'm like,
man,
I don't know man.
You fucking,
people tend to jump off buildings,
quiz.
It does get to some people.
What gets to me like a few years ago,
we basically didn't have a summer,
like January went into mid July and then and then it's became fall in September
1st there was no,
we had like four weeks where it was pretty decent out and kind of know summer
and that happens every once in a while.
So maybe global warming would be good for Seattle.
Oh,
global warming's going to be great for Canada and it's going to be great for
Washington state,
Minnesota.
It's going to suck for tax.
It's going to suck for all these places that don't believe in climate change.
Urban in Washington say,
it's like climate change is real.
We have to address it and we're going to be fine.
You fuckers in Texas who don't believe in climate change.
You're all good.
Don't listen to him.
Jesus going to take care of everything.
You all to be fine.
I need you to pray and pray for rain.
The problem is you're not praying hard enough for rain and there's people like
him sodomized and ruin in the whole fuck.
That's fine.
All right.
Thank you brother.
Really,
really appreciate it.
Please follow down on Twitter.
It's fake.
Dan Savage is his Twitter handle.
Your podcast is available on iTunes and available savage,
lovecast.com savage,
lovecast.com all right,
and thanks to our sponsor.
Thanks to Squarespace.
Go to squarespace.com use the code word Joe and make your own website bitch.
Thanks to [inaudible] dot com go to o n n I t use the code word Rogan and save
10% off any and all supplements.
Uh,
we will be back tomorrow with the one and Only Mad Flavor,
Aka Oh,
is that Wednesday?
Joey's on Wednesday?
Yeah.
Joey's on Wednesday.
Wednesday.
Joey d is a,
and then Thursday the Great Duke Roufus,
one of the best striking trainers in the world today.
Former World Moy Thai champion.
He will be here on Thursday and uh,
maybe another one.
Throw it in there if I find somebody interesting.
Alright,
we love you.
We'll see you soon.
Big Kiss Mom.